[Musique]
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Euh on vous reçoit
dans le cadre de votre activité
concernant l'étude du Moyen-Orient. un
petit peu ce qui se passe en ce moment
avec l'Arabie Saoudite, le Qatar,
la Turquie, la Syrie,
les Cur, le Liban,
l'Iran, toutes ces petites joyeusés.
Est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement ? On va commencer par Agnè
Levalois.
Donc Agnèvalois, moi j'ai travaillé,
j'ai appris l'arabe quand j'étais jeune.
Donc je suis diplômée des langues et de
sciences po avec un DEA sur le monde
arabe contemporain. Et en fait, je
travaille depuis presque 40 ans
maintenant sur ce monde arabe
contemporain, sur les évolutions
géopolitiques, sur l'évolution des
sociétés. J'ai travaillé au départ
surtout sur le proche-orient, ce qu'on
appelle le proche-orient, donc la Syrie
où j'ai passé 2 ans pour apprendre
l'arabe. Après le les j'ai beaucoup
travaillé sur l'Égypte, la Palestine, le
Liban et puis après je me suis
intéressée au pays du golf qui sont
quand même des pays où il se passe
beaucoup de choses en ce moment. Donc
l'Arabie Saoudite, le Qatar, les Émirats
mais également l'Iran. Et puis j'ai
aussi travaillé un peu sur le Maghreb
qui quand même sont les pays les plus
proches dans lesquels il se passe aussi
des choses intéressantes. L'Algérie en
ce moment qui est quand même une période
qui vit une période tout à fait
étonnante, le Maroc, la Tunisie. Voilà
donc ça fait des dizaines d'années que
je me promène, que je travaille que
j'essaie de d'observer de et d'essayer
de comprendre ce qui se joue dans tous
ces pays de cette région.
Pierre Cola, bonsoir.
Vous remarquerez que partout où elle va,
il y a la révolution où il y a le
pagaille quand même hein.
Ouais. sur ce point
comme George McKen c'est ça non ?
Pardon ? Comm
comme Mcin ?
Non, moi j'ai passé à Trump carrément le
On se présente succintement pardon.
On se présente succintement Pierre.
Ouais. Pierre connaît ça. Donc moi, je
suis ancien au fonctionnaire. J'ai
commencé par une agrégation d'histoire,
j'ai enseigné et puis ensuite j'ai passé
l'ENAT et j'ai fait différentes choses
dont une vingtaine d'années au ministère
de la défense à faire tout sauf de
l'administration. Et puis les 10
dernières années, j'ai dirigé une
société intelligence économique. Alors,
je n'ai pas de spécialité géographique.
Moi, ce qui m'intéresse justement que
dans le processus de mondialisation,
c'est pouvoir de comparer les aires
géographiques. Et c'est ça qui
m'intéresse parce que la pensée
stratégique, contrairement à ce qu'on
peut imaginer, n'est pas une pensée
rationnelle, c'est une pensée
idéologique. Et donc, pourquoi certaines
régions attirent plus la pensée
stratégique ? Et pourquoi est-ce qu'on
est plus influencé par certains modes de
réflexion américain que par des
réflexions
venant ? D'ailleurs si vous voulez une
des questions simples pour pour vos
auditeurs, c'est que je comprends
toujours pas pourquoi l'ennemi c'est
Poutine et pas vous de Ben Salman.
On va peut-être traiter ce sujet là un
peu plus tard pendant l'interview. Agnès
Levalois, je vais vous poser toute une
question sur l'Arabie Saoudite. L'Arabie
Saoudite, elle en est où après avoir
passé un journaliste au coupe coupe
balancer les morceaux dans un puit
avec un commando qui écoutait de la
musique pendant que il désossait le
pauvre monsieur ? Euh, est-ce qu'ils ont
ils sont sur une campagne de
recrédibilisation,
ils sont sur une campagne de la
diplomatie du carnet de chèque ? Ils en
sont encore à ça ? Ils essayent de se
racheter une conscience, ils essayent de
donner un peu plus de droit aux femmes.
Qu'est-ce qu'ils font ?
En fait, je crois que
Est-ce que vous irez passer vos vacances
là-bas ?
Non, j'irais passer les vacances là-bas.
J'y suis allée à plusieurs reprises.
C'est toujours intéressant de toute
façon quand on s'intéresse à un pays, à
une société de pouvoir y aller, de
pouvoir rencontrer quelques quelques
personnes, même si c'est difficile de
rencontrer des des Saoudiens en dehors
d'un cadre très formalisé, hein, faut
être ou alors il faut y aller à de
nombreuses reprises pour arriver à
pénétrer cette société, ce qui est pas
une société dans laquelle on arrive
comme ça et les portes s'ouvrent
instantanément. Donc ça c'est quand même
un point qui est qui est important. Euh
c'est un pays qui essae après donc
l'affaire Rachoji de retrouver une
certaine crédibilité sur la scène
internationale. Finalement le prince
héritier y arrive assez facilement parce
que beaucoup de pays sont intéressés par
l'Arabie Saoudite en raison de
l'importance des contrats qui peuvent
être signés. Donc on a mis assez
facilement de côté finalement toutes les
questions des droits de l'homme dont
cell de Raji. On a vu pendant quelques
mois quand même un prince héritier qui
avait été un peu déstabilisé par cette
affaire puisqu'il y a quand même eu un
certain nombre de de critiques qui ont
été assez qui se sont exprimées. Et le
roi d'ailleurs a très bien compris le
danger qu'il y avait euh à laisser son
fils tout gérer tout seul. Et donc on a
vu le roi qui l'a qui a pris son fils
sous le bras et qui a refait la tournée
dans l'intérieur du pays pour rassurer
les Saoudiens sur ce qu'avait fait quand
même son fils. Puisque il y a une chose
moi qui m'est apparue très fort au
lendemain de cette affaire et que
beaucoup de Saoudiens m'ont dit ça n'est
pas dans les habitudes des Saoudiens de
mener ce genre d'opération.
Et donc les Saoudiens ont été très
choqués par la brutalité de ce qui avait
été ou en tous les cas c'est le message.
Qu'est-ce que vous entendez parler
Saoudiens ? Vous parlez des 30000 qui
tiennent le pouvoir ou vous parlez du
reste ? Non non, je parle des gens qui
ne sont pas aux manettes, des saoudiens,
quelques saoudiens que j'ai pu voir qui
disaient "Mais ça n'est pas dans notre
culture ce genre de pratique qu'on qu'on
élimine des opposants qu'on les
emprisonne qui a des procès." Oui, ça et
il y a des la peine de mort la peine de
mort existe ça c'est mais dans un cadre
relativement si vous voulez oui ça mais
dans un cadre si vous voulez ils se sont
sentis un petit peu choqués par un
journaliste passé choqué. Oui,
absolument. Et par toutes les scènes qui
ont été relatées, à savoir que celui qui
avait l'ass qui écoute la musique
classique
donc ça c'est quelque chose qui a
vraiment heurté une partie des
Saoudiens, même si effectivement il y a
des pratiques à l'intérieur du royaume
qui ne sont pas non plus des pratiques
très reluisantes. C'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire.
Lesquel ?
Bah la lapidation et la peine de mort
qui est régulièrement
pratiquée et qui est l'objet de de qui
se fait en public. C'est-à-dire que les
les les lapidations ou les ces
mesures-là sont faites vraiment en
public. Tous tous les Saoudiens peuvent
aller voir. Alors, on y va en famille
pour regarder ce qu'il en est. Donc si
vous voulez ça c'est quelque chose qui
fait partie bon on a vu ça dans d'autres
pays arabes en Syrie. J'ai vu la même
chose des des pendaisons le le vendredi
matin sur la place de des Abacides en
plein Damas et c'était un spectacle et
tout le monde allait voir les
pendaisons. Mais donc cette ce genre de
scène lorsqu'elles sont organisées en
Arabie Saoudite, c'est vrai que les
Saoudiens savent que ça existe et
peuvent y aller. Et ce qui s'est passé à
Istanbul, ça a vraiment été un
traumatisme pour beaucoup de Saoudiens
parce qu'en plus normalement un consulat
de son propre pays à l'étranger est un
lieu où on est en on est protégé, on est
en sécurité et donc le sentiment que là
il y avait quand même un nombre de
règles qui avaient complètement volé en
éclat et que ça ça posait problème pour
une partie des Saoudiens. Donc le roi a
très bien compris que cette ce qui
s'était passé parce que tout le monde
savait que son fils était quand même
responsable de près ou de loin mais on
pouvait pas dire que le prince n'avait
pas été au courant de ce qui se passait
même s'il a pas été forcément au courant
dans les détails, j'en sais rien et je
ça change pas fondamentalement de toute
façon la nature de ce qui s'est passé.
Mais donc le roi
ça change pas
ben que le que le prince héritier est su
c'est je pense que c'est pas lui qui a
dit vous découpez en morceau en écoutant
telle musique classique. C'est ça que je
veux dire mais il était au courant de
cette opération et il a donné son son
aval pour que l'opération se déroule à
savoir que cet opposant ne disparaisse
parce que c'est un opposant qui était
très dangereux pour le royaume, qui
était très dangereux pour le prince
héritier parce que cet opposant qui
n'était pas un vrai opposant pour moi
Rachoji n'est pas un opposant. Ratouji,
c'est un journaliste qui a été qui
faisait partie de la cour, qui faisait
partie des proches de la famille royale,
qui a couvert d'ailleurs pendant des
années, son père était très proche de la
cour également qui faisait partie du
système mais qui justement était
d'autant plus dangereux que c'est
quelqu'un du système qui est parti et
qui à ce moment-là a commencé à
critiquer ce que faisait le prince
héritier. Et ça pour le prince héritier,
c'est insupportable. Donc ce genre
d'opposants, il faut les faire
disparaître alors que des opposants,
j'allais dire plus classiques, qui ne
font pas partie de l'entourage du régime
peuvent critiquer. Il se retrouve en
prison en Arabie Saoudite mais on ne va
pas les éliminer de la sorte comme ça a
été le cas de de Rachogi.
Juste une remarque sur le cas Cachodi.
Cachodi est le 5e de la catégorie à
avoir disparu de la surface de la Terre.
Les quatre précédents sont dans la même
catégorie, c'est-à-dire ce que j'ai
appelé les princes féons, c'est-à-dire
ceux qui sont proches du pouvoir qui se
permettaient de l'étranger de critiquer,
mais avec cette inconscience de pour au
moins deux d'entre eux de monter dans un
avion loué par l'ambassade saoudienne
locale et au lieu de se retrouver à Rome
ou à Bruxelles se retrouver à Riad. Donc
il y a cette idée que pourquoi n'a-t-on
pas parlé des quatre autres ? Donc je
reviens sur un thème médiatique
important. L'Arabie Saoudite a réussi à
installer dans le le champ médiatique
l'idée que c'est un pays rétrograde et
content de l'être et que après tout va
pourquoi va-t-on faire une sur un prince
milliardaire saoudien qui disparaît ?
Là, c'est parce que Cachogi, on a
accumulé tout ce qui devait donner la
caractéristique de cette crise,
c'est-à-dire le fait qu'ils l'ont fait
dans un consulat saoudien à l'étranger,
que le type a découpé en morceaux et
qu'en plus il ne s'était pas rendu
compte que leur consulat était
totalement sonorisé par les Turcs. Donc
évidemment, les Turcs ont géré
extraordinairement habilement cette
affaire en sortant les informations au
fur et à mesure que le comment dire
qu'on que les Saoudiens étaient obligés
à reculer. Alors, les Saoudiens ont fait
jouer une partie de leur réseau
d'influence puisqueil y a un célèbre
journaliste français qui s'appelle
Alexandre Adler. qui avant que le
Mohamed Ben Salman ne reconnaisse sa
responsabilité a créé un article dans le
Figaro Vox pour dire d'après mes sources
de renseignement ce ne sont pas les
Saoudiens ce sont les Turcs. Donc tu
vois il y a eu quelques mobilisations
comme ça mais c'est resté relativement
discret parce que évidemment moi qui a
fait une étude sur le lobby saoudien je
peux dire que quand je l'ai commencé
avant et qu'elle s'est poursuivi après,
les mêmes interlocuteurs avaient changé
de face. Ils étaient devenus plus blem.
C'est du c'est c'est quoi ? C'est de
l'opportunisme médiatique. C'est c'est
quoi ? Non, c'est c'est un système plus
particulier euh si tu veux entre des
diplomates qui vont dire "La raison
d'État, c'est d'avoir de bonnes
relations avec ce pays qui est un gros
client, entre les hommes d'affaires qui
vont dire : "Attendez, c'est un énorme
contrat et cetera, donc on se tait." ou
les dirigeants de la communauté
musulmane qui disent "Mais si on
critique l'Arabie Saoudite, on critique
l'Islam." Si tu veux, tu as une
conjonction de gens qui font que on ne
traite pas de l'Arabie Saoudite comme on
traiterait de la Syrie, de de l'Irak ou
de l'Égypte. Et ça c'est une espèce de
consensus du silence parce que c'est ça
la ligne de communication des saoudiens.
C'est moins on parle de nous plus on est
content.
Agè
sauf que ça ça a changé. C'est vrai que
jusque-là, c'était moins on parle de
nous, mieux on se porte et ça a été le
cas jusqu'à l'arrivée aux affaires de
Mohaben Salman, donc le prince héritier
qui lui est rentré dans une toute autre
logique qui était une logique au
contraire de communication et de faire
de d'abord d'imposer des réformes et de
dire maintenant on va changer la la
perception de l'Arabie Saoudite et
surtout on va changer l'Arabie Saoudite
de l'intérieur. C'est-à-dire que
l'Arabie Saoudite, moi je je présente
mon plan Vision 2030 qui est un plan qui
consiste à moderniser l'économie. Donc
pour ça, il faut moderniser aussi la
société. Et MBS, c'est plus simple que à
chaque fois dire Mohaben Salman a très
bien compris qu'il y avait des signaux à
envoyer aux occidentaux. Les signaux
c'était quoi ? C'était autorisé les
femmes à conduire parce que la question
des femmes est une question qui de toute
façon mobilise évidemment dans les
sociétés occidentales parce que un pays
qui interdit à ces femmes de conduire
c'est juste une absurdité. Donc ça, il a
très bien compris, il l'a joué. Et c'est
d'autant plus une absurdité que dans le
contexte économique de l'Arabie Saoudite
aujourd'hui où la situation économique
est moins reluisante qu'elle n'était il
y a quelques années puisque le prix du
pétrole, il y a eu des périodes où il a
sérieusement baissé et que surtout la
population saoudienne aujourd'hui, elle
est beaucoup plus importante qu'elle
n'était au moment de la création de de
ce royaume dans les années 20 ou 30.
Donc la part du gâteau, c'est-à-dire les
les ressources issues du pétrole
aujourd'hui qu'il faut répartir sur
l'ensemble de la population, bah la part
qui revient à chacun est moindre
aujourd'hui qu'elle n'était auparavant
puisque la population est bien plus
importante. Aujourd'hui, il y a 20
millions de Saoudiens sur une population
de 30 millions d'habitants
parce qu'ils ont pas encore découvert de
nouveaux gisements.
Oui, mais ceci dit, il y a moins
d'argent. Donc s'il y a moins d'argent,
la la redistribution de la mane de la
rente pétrolière est moins grande
qu'elle n'était. Donc les Saoudiens, une
partie des Saoudiens, ce que
j'appelleris ici une classe moyenne qui
est en train d'émerger en Arabie
Saoudite n'a pas les moyens par exemple
d'avoir un chauffeur par famille parce
que la femme n'a pas le droit de
conduire. Parce que dans une famille
lambda saoudienne où la femme jusque-là
n'avait pas le droit de conduire,
l'homme qu'est-ce qu'il faisait ? Il
passait sa journée à faire le chauffeur.
Il fallait emmener les enfants à
l'école, les emmener, aller les
rechercher, aller faire des courses
puisque de toute façon la femme pouvait
rien faire puisquelle était coincée chez
elle. Soit la famille avait de l'argent,
avait un chauffeur et l'homme pouvait
travailler. Mais si la famille n'avait
pas les moyens, l'homme n'avait même
plus le temps d'aller travailler parce
qu'il fallait assurer toute la gestion
de la vie au quotidien. D'un point de
vue économique, c'est juste une
aberration. Donc MBS a fait double coup,
il autorise les femmes à conduire, ce
qui donne une bonne image à l'extérieur.
Et en même temps, ça permet de régler un
des aspects de la situation intérieure
économique où maintenant les femmes
conduisant, bah les hommes peuvent aller
travailler et les femmes peuvent aussi
aller travailler parce que elles sont
plus libres de leur mouvement, elles
sont autonomes. Donc MBS a très bien
compris en arrivant aux affaires qu'il
fallait absolument changer le la vie
économique du pays puisque les Saoudien
jusque-là travaillaient pas ou très peu
et qu'il y avait plus la même ressource
pour assurer le niveau de vie des
Saoudiens et qu'il fallait donc
maintenant se mettre à travailler. Et
donc travailler ça passe par un certain
nombre de mesures qu'il a pris
simplement entre prendre des mesures et
les appliquer. parfois un peu compliqué
parce que les Saoudiens jusque-là
justement n'avaient pas l'habitude de
travailler et vous avez beaucoup
d'entreprises étrangères qui vous disent
avec la loi de la saoudisation des
emplois, c'est-à-dire que chaque société
doit avoir un pourcentage d'employés
saoudiens, sinon ils sont obligés de
payer des taxes, des amendes. Donc les
entreprises embauchent des Saoudiens. Si
on ne trouve pas les profils adaptés,
vous êtes quand même obligé de recruter
des étrangers qui vont faire le travail.
Mais là encore, la rentabilité
économique n'est pas à la hauteur. Donc
il y a tout un système que MBS a voulu
changer dans le cadre de son plan Vision
2030 qui consiste à diversifier
l'économique à l'économie et à créer des
emplois puisque un des drames de
l'Arabie Saoudite aujourd'hui, c'est que
vous avez un taux de chômage des jeunes
absolument énorme. Donc MBS a compris
que si il veut réussir son paris de
moderniser l'Arabie Saoudite et pour
cela avoir le soutien des Saoudiens, il
faut qu'il arrive à créer des emplois
pour les jeunes saoudiens pour que les
jeunes saoudiens le soutiennent dans son
entreprise.
Bon courage, ça va prendre 10 ans ça.
Ah bah évidemment
parce que la plupart sont des cossards
finis. On a pas on les a pas habitué à
travailler. Oui, absolument.
Faut changer le logiciel.
Il réclament tous de toucher le pactol à
chaque fois qu'il bosse pour 2 heures de
boulot. Euh euh il y en a 30000 aux
commandes de l'État entre la police,
l'armée, les fonctionnaires. En fait,
c'est à peu près 30000 personnes qui qui
dirige ce pays.
Euh euh et
les princes,
c'est les princes, c'est surtout les
princes.
C'est ça.
C'est pas les c'est pas ceux qui ont des
cartes de fonctionnaires. J'ai
j'ai eu la chance de connaître une
princesse saoudienne. On avait de la
chance.
Elle m'a expliqué l'intérieur du pays
d'une façon extraordinaire.
Pierre connaît ça. Est-ce que l'Arabie
Saoudite après ces ces ces travaux de
modernisation de façade, est-ce que la
la modernisation du carnet de chèque et
de lob du lobbyisme et l'opportunisme et
le clientélisme du carnet de chèque
saoudien fonctionne toujours ?
Moi je qualifierai pas ça de l'hobi du
carnet de chèque. C'est plutôt le Qatar
qui était le carnet de chèque parce que
le Qatar c'est des nouveaux riches. Les
nouveaux riches si vous voulez c
toujours les nouveaux riches, il
montrent l'argent. Bon et ils ont pensé
qu'il pouvait se faire une réputation
avec euh justement une politique du
carnetchèc sur lesquelles Cheno et
Malbruno ont beaucoup euh publié si tu
veux d'information. Et donc euh c'était
ça la technique Qatarie. Les Saoudiens
ont eu l'intelligence de comprendre
assez tôt que ils ne pouvaient pas euh
se vendre eux-même. Bon pourquoi ?
D'abord parce qu'il y a aucun
intellectuel saoudien exportable sur un
plateau télé. La deuxième chose c'est
parce que le produit l'Arabie Saoudite
est invendable. Donc vous en avez
suffisamment décrit les caractéristiques
si tu veux à part vendre des des
reportages télés sur les décapitations.
Et et troisème chose, ils se sont rendus
compte que finalement moins ont parlé
d'eux, mieux ça valait et ils se sont
très tôt adressés à des boîtes de
relation publique qui ont réussi à les
convaincre que ils sont ils sont ils
vent mieux faire que faire.
Les par exemple, il y a une boîte de
relation publique qui les a démarché
avec une photo de décapitation en disant
si votre justice c'est comme ça, vous
avez besoin d'une bonne boîte de
relation publique. C'est c'est c'est le
résumé d'une photo. Bon, je te la
passerai si tu veux parce qu'elle est
extraordinairement convaincante. C'est
la meilleure pub que j'ai jamais vu.
Quel quelle pub ? De quel cabinet ?
Je sais pas quel était le cabinet. Ce
qui m'intéressait c'est qu'on c'était
une image d'une décapitation en public
puisque les décapitations se passent en
public. Et le truc anglais c'était si
vous avez une justice comme celle-là,
vous avez vraiment besoin d'une bonne
boîte de relation publique. Donc je sais
pas laquelle c'était mais enfin si tu
veux c'est pour dire combien ils ont
compris qu'il valait mieux s'adresser à
des boîtes de relation publique. Et si
tu veux, ils ont aujourd'hui sous
contrat les cinq majors, les trois
américaines Omniom, WPP, Burstone,
Marsteiner et les deux françaises
publicis et Avas. Et donc ils ont
totalement saturé le marché.
L'originalité du système de lobby
saoudien, c'est que c'est pas du du
qu'on fait pas directement, c'est une
arborescence. C'est-à-dire que
publiciste va sous-traiter avec une
petite boîte qui va inviter des
parlementaires et donc ça permet aux
parlementaires en cas sexe de dire mais
c'est pas on va en Arabie Saoudite mais
c'est pas l'Arabie Saoudite qui nous
invite, c'est une boîte de relation
publique. Donc si tu veux ce système-
làà est aujourd'hui extrêmement fourni
et donc le plus gros opérateur
aujourd'hui dans les relations publiques
de pardon, je reviens une minute en
arrière sur un petit épisode. Le 12
septembre 2001, il y a une boîte qui
s'appelle Corvis qui va approcher
l'ambassade saoui à à Washington en
disant vous avez vraiment besoin d'une
boîte de relation publique. Ils vont
signer tout de suite. Cette boîte Corvi,
c'est aujourd'hui celle qui représente
l'Arabie Saoudite à Bruxelles et c'est
devenu une filiale de publicist. Donc tu
vois comment le système fonctionne,
c'est-à-dire
c'est du business quand même, c'est
normal.
Ah ben j'ai pas dit que c'était J'ai pas
dit que c'était anormal. Ce qui est
intéressant c'est que à Bruxelles, les
boîtes qui font du lobbying sont obligés
de publier leur contrat et de dire qui
est leur commanditaire, chose qui ne se
fait pas au Parlement français
puisque'au Parlement français, il y a
pas de lobby. Donc s'il y a pas de
lobby, c'est pas la peine de demander
aux lobby qu'est-ce qu'ils font. Tu vois
ce que je veux dire ? Le le
l'extraordinaire. Par exemple, tu tu as
une haute autorité à la transparence de
la vie politique française que je
connais. Je connais la secrétaire
générale, on était ensemble au tribunal
administratif de Versailles. Il y a pas
un mot sur les sociétés de relation
publiques qui vont tous les jours au
Parlement français. Pas un mot. C'estàd
ça n'existe pas. Tu vois le l'espèce
d'hypocrisie. Donc on est sur un système
où effectivement je crois qu'Anè a
raison. Mohamed Ben Salman essaie de
faire un certain nombre de réformes. La
viscosité du de la société saoudienne
parce que c'est pas facile quand ton
père a rien foutu. Je vois pas pourquoi
toi tu te mettrais au boulot. Ça me
paraît une conséquence normale. Et donc
les mettre au travail pour leur dire il
faut effectivement avoir de la
productivité puis dans une entreprise
étrangère, tu vas être sous l'autorité
d'un mec qui est pas un saoudien. Ça
fait des vaguelettes si tu veux. Et donc
ce système là il va effectivement
essayer de le faire mais enfin on voit
bien que dès qu'il y a des gens en
particulier des femmes qui réclament
plus bah la sanction tombe. C'est-à-dire
c'est la prison. Vous pouvez conduire si
vous voulez, mais si vous en réclamez un
Yota de plus,
aliès.
Non, ce que je veux dire, cette question
de des femmes mais qu'on voit dans
d'autres domaines, c'est que ce qui est
ce qui a profondément changé avec MBS,
c'est que aujourd'hui le royaume n'est
plus gouverné suivant un système de
consensus de la famille royale
auparavant, dit qu'il y avait une
décision importante à prendre, on
réunissait le conseil qui avec les
quelques princes importants qui
prenaient la décision. MBS a a
complètement cassé ce système et
maintenant c'est un système autoritaire,
j'allais dire traditionnel qu'on voit
dans plein d'autres pays de de la
région. C'est lui lui tout seul qui
décide. Et quand on on pense à cette
histoire des femmes où il accorde le
droit de conduire aux femmes et dans le
même temps, il emprisonne des femmes qui
demandent la levée d'autres mesures en
particulier la mesure du tout. Une femme
pour pouvoir voyager, pouvoir faire
n'importe quoi, devait avoir
l'autorisation de son frère, son mari et
autres. Euh quand les femmes demandent
ça, elles se retrouvent en prison. Et
c'est simplement si je puis dire parce
que MBS qui veut dire clairement à ces
femmes et à toutes à tout citoy enfin il
y a pas de citoyen à tout saoudien c'est
moi qui décide du tempo de la réforme.
Je n'accepterai jamais de mener une
réforme en réaction à une demande de la
population. Donc il a accordé le droit
des femmes et il voulait dans son
intention c'était de continuer à
accorder d'autres droits parce qu'il a
très bien compris que vis-à-vis de
l'Occident c'était sa carte maîtresse.
C'est ce qui lui permet de faire passer
plein d'autres choses par derrière. S'il
ouvre, s'il donne engage à l'Occident
l'ouverture des droits aux femmes, il
peut obtenir plein d'autres choses par
derrière parce que c'est quelque c'est
c'est un sujet qui mobilise en Occident
à juste titre. Mais ce qu'il veut
surtout, c'est de dire "C'est moi qui
impose le tempo des réformes et ça sera
jamais personne qui me qui m'imposera
quoi que ce soit." Raison pour laquelle
les Saoudiens sont à la tête de la
contre-révolution à la suite des
révolutions dans le monde arabe parce
que pour les Saoudiens, c'est
inacceptable de laisser des changements
intervenir après un soulèvement d'une
population parce que ça peut ça va
pouvoir arriver un jour peut-être en
Arabie. Donc il faut pas l'accepter. Je
vais vous poser une question très
provoque et peut-être très vulgaire.
Donc je je m'en excuse d'avance. Un
jour, je discutais avec un avocat qui
était très connu qui s'appelait Jacques
Verges
et il me disait voilà la France est
devenue la [__] des Amériques. Alors
moi je vais je vais rechanger cette
question. Tu vois c'était son
affirmation mais moi je vais poser une
question. J'ai je vais vous poser la
question suivante. Est-ce que la France
est devenue la [__] des saoudiens ?
Bah
elle est pas plus devenue la [__] que
les Saoudiens que les autres. On est
dans des relations d'intérêt. On est et
que la France, les pays occidentaux, les
pays européens, les États regardez les
États-Unis, quand Trump va à Riad,
qu'est-ce qu'il fait ? Il il montre un
énorme chèque de soi-disant 500
milliards de dollars qu'il a obtenu de
MBS. Il a rien obtenu du tout. C'est de
la pub. Mais pour montrer, on est dans
une relation commerciale économique.
Alors nous les Français, on va pas dire
ça aussi brutalement parce qu'on n'a pas
la même façon de dire les choses.
Non non, nous on va dire nous avons des
intérêts stratégiques que nous voulons
défendre. Nous avons une relation
d'intérêt avec le monde arabo-musulman
et nous aurons en plus un courant
d'affaires avec le le pays. Trump il est
brut de découffrage, il montre son
chèque de 500 milliards de dollars. Il
est content et il repart.
Bon mais à terme c'est ce qu'il veut. il
a annoncé qu'il voudrait arriver à 500
milliards. Bon, nous euh évidemment
qu'on veut avoir un flux euh commercial
économique avec l'Arabie, on a'aura
jamais ces sommes-là. Et de toute façon
dans les mêmes les 100 milliards
annoncés par Trump, je voudrais bien
savoir quelle est la réalité de ce qui a
été décaissé par les Saoudiens. On est
loin de ces chiffres délirants, bien
sûr. Et la France, on a à chaque fois 10
milliards. Nous dès qu'on a un homme de
un ministre qui va en Arabie, c'est 10
milliards. On sait pas où ils vont
passer. Mais on va accompagner ça d'un
discours en disant oui mais parce que
nous avons une relation des intérêts
stratégiques. Abu Dhabi n'est pas très
loin, on a une base. Enfin voilà, on a
des et puis on a un intérêt pour le
monde arabe. L'Arabie Saoudite est loin
des États-Unis. Le le monde arabe est
proche de l'Europe et de la France en
particulier.
Juste une remarque sur ce ce que disait
Agnè. Euh
le passage en force de Mohamed Ben
Salman s'est produit de différentes
manières. Bon, d'abord, ils ont cassé
l'ordre de succession normale qui est ce
qu'on appelle un ordre adelphique,
c'est-à-dire c'était le premier fils de
la première femme, ensuite cit le
premier fils de la deuxième femme du
père fondateur de Abdelaziz, ensuite le
premier film de la fils de la trisème
femme et cetera. Et donc c'est pour ça
que tu avais souvent des querelles entre
des nonagénères et des octogénaires pour
savoir qui allaaiit succéder au
précédent. Moi là pour la première fois,
ils ont cassé le système, c'estàd qu'ils
ont sauté une génération et donc ça
apparaît ce qui a été très bien mise en
évidence par les boîtes de relation
publique. Regardez, c'est le jeune, il
est beau, il a qu'une femme, il a que
deux enfants et cetera. Enfin bref, il
est comme nous. Cela dit, un de ses
premiers gestes, ça a été quand même
l'opération du Ritz. L'opération du
Ritz. Il a donc réuni tous ses petits
marotes de jeu, il les a mis dans un
grand hôtel, il leur a enlevé leur
téléphone portable et il les a laissé
sortir contre des chèqus.
contre ses chècs. Alors, j'ai pas les
montants mais en gros on dit qu'il a
récupéré entre 60 et 100 milliards de
dollars parce que tout ce qu'il avait
autour de lui, c'était ces gens qui se
beurrait dans tous les contrats d'Arabie
Saoudite, y compris sur les nôtres
évidemment hein. Et donc, il s'est fâché
avec une grande partie de ses soutiens
traditionnels. Quand Agnas dit, il a
cassé le mécanisme décisionnel
collectif, il s'est aussi fait beaucoup
d'ennemis. Bon, autre aspect qui me
paraît très intéressant, c'est que ceux
qui avaient pas d'argent sur eux, ils
ont pu payer en actif, c'est-à-dire
donner des biens de société, y compris
du groupe MBC qui est le grand groupe de
communication saoudien. C'est-à-dire que
Mohamed Ben Salman, non seulement il a
récupéré du pognon, mais en plus il a
récupéré des médias. Et puis troisème
chose, mais je termine là-dessus parce
que c'est je veux pas être trop long, il
s'est quand même acheté un yacht à 600
millions de dollars qu'il a racheté un
oligarque russe et il s'est acheté un
château à machin là à côté de Paris qui
est une copie de Versailles. Donc l'idée
de l'homme de la lutte anticorruption,
il faut le prendre dans une perspective
médiatique, pas dans une perspective
réaliste. Et donc à forceori chez ces
gens-là qui à qui on demande tout à coup
de travailler, qui on pèse les
allocations, à qui on va imposer de la
TVA, il connaissez pas la TVA. Et donc
cela, on va leur dire mais attendez
votre prince, il s'est payé c payé ça.
C'est-à-dire que ça entretient malgré
tout une espèce de d'accrimonie qui va
peut-être pas se manifester par des
manifestations de rue, mais enfin il
faut quand même penser que la plus
grosse armée saoudienne, c'est la garde
nationale. He la garde nationale, elle
est là pour consolider le régime. Elle
est à la limite mieux armée que la
l'armée saoudienne. Bon donc on est sur
un système où encore une fois, il faut
pas donner le sentiment que l'homme est
le grand réformateur. C'est pas la
tature que de l'Arabie Saoudite. Et en
même temps, dans cette histoire de de
Rit Carlton, il y a une partie et les
jeunes saoudiens ont on ont apprécié
cette mesure estimant qu'effectivement
le prince allait aller chercher l'argent
là où il était, même si lui entre-temps,
il s'est effectivement acheté ce yach,
il a acheté ce fameux tableau d'Éléonard
de Vincy dont on a beaucoup parlé. Mais
ça a été un point qui a été très bien
perçu par la jeune génération des
Saoudiens en se disant "Bon ben c'est
bien, on va il va récupérer une partie
de cet argent." Et donc euh toute la
crédibilité maintenant de MBS vis-à-vis
des jeunes qui sont majoritaires dans ce
pays. Je ce qui est important de voir
c'est que effectivement pourquoi les
jeunes soutiennent MBS parce qu'ils ont
sentiment que pour la première fois ils
peuvent se reconnaître dans ce dans ce
prince même s'il a des comportements qui
peuvent qui ont démontré des
comportements quand même plus que
surprenants et scandaleux.
Bah l'histoire à Shouji et compagnie.
Mais il n'empêche que pour les jeunes,
c'est euh il représente une un visage
qui est beaucoup plus acceptable que
tous ces ces vieux dirigeants qu'ils ont
eu jusque-là de moyenne d'âge 80 85 ans.
Et donc ils accordent encore à MBS le
bénéfice de de du doute et et le
bénéfice qu'il veut vraiment changer des
choses. Maintenant, ce qui va être très
compliqué pour MBS, c'est que s'il
n'arrive pas assez vite à démontrer que
les mesures qu'il a prises apportent
vraiment des améliorations pour ces
jeunes de travail, de pouvoir vivre à
peu près correctement, s'il perd le
soutien de ses jeunes, là, il sera nu.
Donc ce qui est important pour lui,
c'est d'arriver à à avoir des résultats
assez forts. Donc, il a fait des coûts
comme le coût du rison qui qui a été
apprécié. Nous à ce moment-là, on
faisait une veille des réseaux sociaux
euh du monde arabe travaillant à la
fondation pour la recherche stratégique.
On faisait une veille des des réseaux
sociaux et c'était intéressant de voir à
quel point les jeunes saoudiens
applaudissaient des demains dans cette
campagne de MBS.
Cette veille, elle se faisait comment ?
Ben, on regarde les réseaux sociaux,
donc on avait tout un tas de de comptes
et qu'on regardait pour voir ce que
disaient les jeunes. Parce que comme il
y a pas de scène politique en Arabie
Saoudite, comment vous voulez savoir ce
que pensent les gens ? Vous regardez les
réseaux sociaux. D'ailleurs, le roi
lui-même peut prendre des mesures ou
défaire des mesures qu'il a prises
lorsqu'il s'aperçoit que sur les réseaux
sociaux, il y a une campagne qui
commence à prendre de l'importance et le
roi plusieurs fois est revenu en arrière
en partie quand il a voulu imposer des
impôts parce qu'il y a pas d'impôts en
Arabie Saoudite et quand il a commencé à
dire "On va on va imposer des impôts, il
y a eu une fronte sur les réseaux
sociaux absolument considérable. Du
coup, il a fait marche arrière parce
qu'il s'est rendu compte que c'était
beaucoup trop impopulaire. Donc les
réseaux sociaux, quand on travaille sur
l'Arabie Saoudite, c'est la première
chose à regarder, à étudier parce que
vous prenez la température de ce qui se
dit, des réactions et comment vous
pouvez essayer d'adapter si vous voulez
être un peu en prise avec ce qui se
passe.
Alors, je je vais vous poser une
question un peu provoque à tous les
deux. Euh en tant qu'ancien, vous êtes
vous avez traîné un peu avec le Kedorse
tous les deux, non ?
Ministère de la défense plutôt.
Ah, c'est mieux le ministère de la
défense, ça va.
et ministère de la défense aussi
c'est-à-dire
bah bosser un peu là-bas
ou que vous avez béboué
alors
ma question ma question c'est
imaginez-vous vous êtes diplomate vous
travaillez au qu d'ors
vous n'êtes pas la la [__] des
saoudiens mais vous apprenez le matin
que bon quand même les gars avec qui
vous allez voyager ils ont passé un
journaliste au coupe couple qui l'ont
fait disparaître façon film d'horreur
d'exter
comment Vous faites comment vous
imaginez le diplomate
qui va bosser le matin pour continuer
son petit urbain, sa petite planque, son
petit son petit vernis du qu d'ors ?
Vous comprenez ? Ça fait bien dans les
dîners à Noël. Vous faites quoi dans la
vie ? Je travaille au qu d'ors
mais ça ressemble plus à une planque
chose maintenant le qu d'ors ? Non
non, faut pas exagérer quand même. Non,
il y a quand même des
Attendez alors il faut pas exagérer.
Pourquoi ? Racontez-moi
si tu veux. Je crois que tu as la
question te choque parce que ça parle de
cachoti. Mais si tu penses à la
politique africaine de la France, ça te
donne une épaisseur historique qui fait
que quand tu es diplomate, il faut que
tu air dur et que tu es sois l'adepte
d'un certain cynisme. C'est-à-dire, tu
es chargé de tenir la position
officielle française et donc il faut que
tu dises ce que le qued d'oré te dit de
dire.
C'est quoi le qued d'Orset ?
Ben le qued d'ors c'est un ministre avec
qui participe à un conseil des ministres
et qui décide de la ligne officielle. Ce
matin, j'étais à une réunion sur le la
crise du Rwanda. La crise du Rwanda.
Pour te donner une idée, euh quand le
génocide commence, madame Abia Rimana,
la femme du président qui qui était la
directrice, la chef des milices
interamoué qui qui était en train de
massacrer dans la rue, prend l'avion et
arrive à Paris et on lui donne 200000
francs en liquide pour qu'elle
s'installe. Donc je te retourne la
question. Cela c'était la cellule
Afrique de l'Élysée, c'était pas les
diplomates. Il y a un cynisme du pouvoir
qui est extraordinaire. La question que
tu poses sur l'Arabie Saoudite, il faut
pas la prendre comme si la France était
la [__] de la de l'Arabie Saoudite. La
France est une puissance de second rang
pour les Saoudiens. C'est-à-dire les
seuls qui craignent, c'est les
Américains. Donc quand des gens comme la
France ou comme le Canada se permettent
de critiquer, je prends l'exemple du
Canada parce que quand les femmes ont
été arrêtées, le ministre canadien a dit
que c'était scandaleux et cetera. Les
Saoudiens n'ont fait ni une ni, ils ont
coupé les relations diplomatiques.
Mais alors et mais alors quand même le
contrat d'armement pour les 10 milliards
de véhicules blindé vendu par le Canada
a continué quand même he je te rassure.
C'estàdire on ne se parlait plus mais on
continue à vendre. Donc on est dans ce
cyisme là dans les relations
internationales. Le la France est comme
les autres c'est-à-dire si elle l'ouvre
trop elle est sanctionnée parce qu'on
est sur un régime dans lequel il y a pas
à passer par le parlement pour dire on
arrête nos contrats on nachètera plus
chez vous. Donc c'est ça la relation.
C'est une relation dans la de mettre à
esclave. Sauf que effectivement c'est
comme dans la relation du maître
esclave, c'est le maître qui a besoin de
l'esclave, c'est pas le l'esclave qui a
besoin du maître.
En même temps, moi je je crois quand
même, il faut pas caricaturer la
situation. C'est-à-dire que les
diplomates euh moi je suis pas diplomate
et si je n'ai pas choisi cette carrière,
c'est parce que ça me cenait pas. Donc
je suis pas là pour défendre les
diplomates. Elle se caricature tout de
suite.
Non non non, elle se caricature,
c'est une caricature quand on voit la
position du Kor de temps en temps, c'est
ce qui n'êche,
c'est un théâtre.
Ce qui n'empêche et c'est important
quand même de
Comment on l'appelait l'autre le dormeur
du qued d'ors ? C'était quoi son petit
nom là ? Comment on appelait comment ?
le dormeur du Koré.
Non mais ça, on peut trouver toutes les
caricatures sur un certain nombre de de
diplomates. Peu importe. Ce que je veux
simplement dire, c'est qu'il y a une
expertise au quorsé quand même.
Ah bon ? Alors
oui, laisse laissez-moi finir. Il y a
une expertise au qu d'ors il y a des
diplomates qui connaissent les sujets
sur lesquels ils travaillent.
Des noms, des noms ?
Ben non, mais il y a un nombre de des
diplomates qui sont alors si on parle de
notre zone qui sont al
les diplomates, c'est lesquels ? C'est
ceux qui sont dans les les salons
feutrés qui mangent des petits rochers
succhat. Laissez-moi finir. Laissez-moi
finir. Les diplomates qui pour beaucoup
d'entre eux parlentabe, connaissent
cette région, ont séjourné ses séjournes
qui ont une sensibilité, une
connaissance qui leur permet de dire,
d'écrire des choses. Après, la question
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on va faire de ces
travaux
au niveau du cabinet du ministre ? Mais
je crois qu'on peut pas caricaturer et
dire simplement les diplomates, c'est
simplement des chocolats qui qu'on
distribue dans dans des réceptions tous
les soirs avec la coupe de champagne. On
va sortir de la correction. Non non Agnè
Agnè donc la caricature laissez-moi
finir parce que je pense que c'est
important
les diplomates on les voit jamais dans
la rue.
Mais bien il y en a enfin moi d'abord
j'en ai vu quand même dans la rue qui
allaient parler qui allaient stater la
la situation qui allaient dans les
manifestations pour savoir ce qui se
passait. Donc il y a des diplomates qui
le font pas tous. C'est pas
l'ambassadeur qui va y aller, il a le
responsable de la presse qui est si
c'est un jeune qui connaît l'arabe, si
ça se passe dans un pays arabe, il va y
aller parce que c'est ça qui l'amuse,
c'est ça qui l'intéresse et c'est ce
pourquoi il est payé et que il y a quand
même, il a du coup une possibilité en
rentrant d'écrire des choses qui peuvent
être ou non qui peuvent être ou non
utilisées par les dcsideurs. Mais je
crois qu'il faudrait pas donner
l'impression parce que c'est c'est à mon
avis c'est faux qu'il n'y a absolument
pas d'expertise de connaissance de
connaissance du terrain.
Oui oui mais bien sûr. Et et moi je
exprès je je j'ess pas une caricature
ça peut être
le qu d'ors le qued d'ors il s ils sont
un petit peu trop ils s'endorment sur
leur réputation
pas tous pas tous. Non, je crois qu'il
faut enfin je sais pas moi ça fait 30
ans que j'en croise parce que quand je
vais me balader, soit je passe pas
systématiquement par l'ambassade mais
quand je connais quelqu'un je vais le
voir et je connais un certain nombre et
j'en connais beaucoup de diplomates sur
la région qui connaissent cette région
avec un une vraie connaissance avec des
des réseaux avec
Comment vous expliquez qu'ils ont jamais
vu les révolutions arabes débarquer ?
Mais ils les ont vu plutôt arrêter avec
cette question de Mais c'est pas vrai.
C'est pas vrai. C'est comme quand on a
dit les chercheurs n'ont pas vu les
révolutions arabes. Nous on a écrit nous
les chercheurs, les analystes et
certains et certains
attendez et certains diplomat qu'est-ce
qu'on écrivait depuis des années ? On
décrivait depuis des années qu'il y
avait des mouvements sociaux qui étaient
des mouvements sociaux importants en
Égypte en particulier avec tous les
mouvements qu'il y avaient dans les
usines dans les banlieux de de du CER.
Ça, on le voyait, on l'écrivait en
disant que c'était des signaux d'une
situation qui allait à un moment
exploser. On pouvait pas donner le jour,
l'heure évidemment, mais ces signaux
qu'on a mis en avant, les chercheurs, un
de diplomates. Après, la question c'est
qui vous a pas écouté ?
Bah le le pouvoir politique, c'est c'est
la couche au-dessus que ça ne passe pas.
C'est ça le problème. C'est pas au
niveau des chercheurs, des analystes et
des diplomates de terrain. Quand vous
rediscutez, vous reprenez nombre de
télégramlo, des choses était dit. Après,
est-ce qu'on a envie de les entendre et
d'en faire quelque chose ou non ? C'est
une autre question. Et là maintenant, il
faut interviewer des décideurs, des
diplomates mais au plus haut niveau au
cabinet et des ministres pour savoir ce
qu'ils font de cette expertise. Il faut
pas se tromper làdessus. Non, mais quand
on appelle le doré, quand on appelle le
Kedors, ils sont jamais là. Non non non
attends attends. La chose c'est qu'il
faut voir que le décideur n'a pas que
les que le quedoré comme source
d'information. Moi j'ai fait une
expérience après le génocide du Rwanda
où une question qui me tarodait c'était
les autorités avaient-elles les moyens
de savoir que le génocide allait
exploser ? Donc on a repris avec mon
équipe tous les télégrammes
diplomatiques de 2 ans avant, toutes les
notes de la DGSE de 2 ans avant, toutes
les notes de la direction du
renseignement militaire de 2 ans avant.
C'est-à-dire, on se mettait dans la
position de l'officiel qui était informé
par les différents canaux dont le
quedors. Là effectivement, il y a eu une
faillite extraordinaire du quedé parce
que il y a la cellule Afrique de
l'Élysée, c'est-à-dire que tu avais
effectivement des gens qui étaient
directement l'accès auprès de la
présidence et donc le diplomate qui
était sur place où la direction Afrique
n'était pas si tu veux dans le dans un
système d'influence. il pesait pas de
son par contre la DGSE, la DRM, elle
disait "Ne recevez pas tel type, il a
les mains pleines de sens à cause du du
massacre de 92 et cetera et cetera."
Donc il faut voir ça comme ça,
c'est-à-dire les diplomates, il faut
faire faut faire comprendre à son
ministre que vraiment le monde entier
attend ce qu'il va dire. Je caricature
qu'à moitié. Je me suis amusé une fois à
écrire un télégramme diplomatique sans
objet
parce que cet argumentaire, on l'a
entendu des milliers de fois niè comme
moi, on l'a lu des centaines de fois
même si tu es affecté au Nicaragua et
que tout le monde se fout de ce que la
France va va dire. Tu ne peux pas écrire
ça comme comme diplomate. Par exemple,
j'ai un ami qui est ambassadeur dans un
pays de l'Est
dans lequel il y a eu une élection
populiste, si tu veux et après quelques
mois, il a dit "OK, Dorsé, faites
attention, l'homme est populaire, ne le
critiquez pas de face, c'est pas comme
ça que vous l'aurez". Et cetera.
son télégramme a fuité dans la presse,
le mec a été rappelé. Donc tu comprends
bien que c'est une logique le système.
Le système c'est il faut faire
comprendre au chef que vraiment le monde
entier attend ce qu'il va dire. Et alors
tu fais une bonne carrière ou tu es tu
es honnête, tu le dis avec les formes,
mais tu as aussi autour du ministre des
gens qui vont lui dire tous les matins,
monsieur le ministre, vous avez raison,
monsieur le ministre, quelle bonne idée,
monsieur le ministre. Et cela joue le
filtre. Cela joue le filtre. Ils disent
non l'opinion moi une fois il y a un mec
qui m'a dit dans un cabinet c'était au
ministère de la défense le ministre a
décidé que je dis c'est dommage que nos
ennemis ne lisent pas nos notes sinon
ils saurait à quoi s'en tenir tu
comprends le renversement de truc donc
les diplomates sont aussi dans un
système où ils ne sont pas totalement
libres alors il y en a certains qui sont
d'une certaine veulerie moi ce qu'on m'a
raconté sur le sur justement le Rwand
c'est que l'ambassadeur était le premier
à embarquer dans l'avion qui évacuit les
ressortissants français
j'ai entendu ça ce matin donc tu vois il
y a des il y a il y a de tout et puis il
y a des diplômates qui sont des hommes
de terrain qui sont capables d'aller
comprendre, d'informer avec toute
l'élégance d'un télégramme diplomatique
mais qui parfois ne font pas de belles
carrières parce que justement ils ont
pas ils ont pas eu le l'oreille du
ministre ou en tout cas l'oreille était
pas ouverte.
Oui, je crois qu'il y a il y a deux
niveaux vraiment. Il y a je crois qu'on
peut pas dire
sur la révolution arabe c'était quand
même des sacrés brêles.
Non mais ça a été géré. Et comment c'est
parti sur les révolutions arabes quand
Alari ministre de la défense des
affaires d'étrangères à l'étoxe
d'une ministre qui qui n'a rien compris
à rien de ce qui est en train de se
passer ce qui ne veut pas dire ce qui ne
veut pas dire que certains diplomates
qui étaient en poste en Tunisie en
Égypte n'avaient pas senti, n'avait pas
vu, n'avait pas fait remonter des
éléments de et Wikileak à ce moment-là a
joué son rôle ou des on voy bien que
dans certains télégramme, il y a des
choses qui avaient été écrites de dire
il faut faire attention donc on peut pas
c'est pour ça que j'ai qu'il faut pas il
faut pas caricaturer quoi
sur la Tunisie en plus l'ambassadeur qui
était là-bas en poste quand Alomar
arrive va là-bas il est rappelé il est
rappelé c'est un copain il a il dit des
choses attention c'est ce genre de
position est très maladroit il a été
rappelé donc il faut voir cette espèce
les services de renseignement, on envoie
un ministre, elle était ministre de la
défense à l'époque. Nonens,
oui, c'est défense. Oui,
on envoie notre ministre de la défense
dans un pays en période
insurrectionnelle instable et il y a pas
une note de la DGSE qui dit quand même
madame le ministre, vous allez là-bas,
c'est quand même un peu dangereux pour
vous.
Elle y allait à titre personnel, elle
allait raconter qu'elle allait acheter
un appartement pour ses grand pour ses
parents
le tout dans un avion d'un homme
d'affaires tunisien. Alors, tu te dis
effectivement il y a quand même beaucoup
d'indicateurs sur lesquels elle aurait
dû elle-même avoir cette cette réaction
de de réticence.
Et donc, tu te retrouve avec des gens
qui te disent "Mais attendez, cher
monsieur, Ali Marie n'a jamais voté les
résolutions condamnant l'Arabie Saoudite
au Parlement européen sur la Fakashogi
?" Ah, je ne sais pas. Je ne sais pas.
Je dis, je constate de même que Rashid
Adati d'ailleurs n'a jamais voté
d'aucune des résolutions du Parlement
européen sur le l'Arabie Saoudite. Donc,
tu peux te poser des questions. Est-ce
qu'elles sont imbéciles ? Je suis pas
sûr. Est-ce qu'elles ont des intérêts
personnels ? Je ne suis pas sûr mais
enfin tu tu es obligé de constater quand
tu as un ministre au-dessus de toi
entouré d'un cabinet qui est là pour le
valoriser. Si tu essayes de faire un son
dissonnant, bah c'est toi qui est
sanctionné.
On fait comment pour en arranger ça
Agnès ?
On démissionne tous. On on respecte les
valeurs de la France. C'estàd que quand
un ministre sans je vais je vais être
très vulgaire mais sans tamponne
euh on démissionne et on va faire autre
chose ou on est tellement bien dans
cette petite cantine qu'on reste là et
qu'on faitoui avec la
forcément qu'on est c'est qu'on dit
qu'on on peut faire de la résistance en
interne aussi et qu'on va continuer pour
certains le sentiment que cette
connaissance qu'ils ont ben il faut
continuer à travailler faut continuer
quand même à alimenter avec des notes
même si il y a 1 % qui va être lu ou qui
va être pris en considération
Après, c'est le choix de chacun de voir
comment il réagit par rapport à ça. Je
C'est quoi la mentalité d'un diplomate
en général ? C'est quoi la mentalité
d'un diplomate ? C'est un long parcours.
On est obligé de de faire des sacrifices
humains pour arriver jusqu'à la place où
on est. C'est marché sur la tête des
autres. Est-ce que le sport national
chez les diplomates, c'est on aime quand
on fait pipi dans un violon ?
Non, mais je je trouve que vraiment
c'est c'est une vision qui est vraiment
encore une fois trop caricaturale.
Moi, je vois tous ceux qui passent.
Alors moi, je vais parler de ceux que je
connais en général passé le ce qu'on
appelle le cadre Orient. C'est-à-dire
que ce sont les diplomates qui sont
passionnés par une zone géographique.
Alors, je vais parler plutôt de ceux que
je connais donc sur ma zone, mais il y a
aussi ceux qui se passionne pour l'Asie,
pour la Russie, pour la Chine, sur la
Syrie ou sur le le monde arabe d'une
façon générale. Moi, j'ai vu des jeunes
diplomates qui viennent de rentrer qui
soit depuis 2 3 ans au K d'Osé qui sont
absolument passionnés, qui ont passé 2
ans en Égypte, en Palestine pour
apprendre l'arabe, pour comprendre.
Ils ont fait un petit voyage payé par
les impôts. Non, non, non, non, non,
non, non, non, non, non, non, non. Ils
ont passé de langues deux langues
régionales qu'ils ont appris avant et
après ils passent le concours. Ils ont
le concours pas forcément la première
fois parce qu'il y a deux trois postes
et il y en a pas beaucoup. Il y a
beaucoup de candidats qui le repassent
qui l'ont et qui sont absolument
passionnés et qui est eux. Alors moi
évidemment quand il m'en parle
maintenant avec moi le recul et le le
fait que je suis en fin de carrière euh
je ils ont un côté un peu naïf mais en
même temps heureusement qu'il y a encore
des jeunes qui croient qui vont qui vont
passer 2 3 ans 5 ans, 6 ans à prendre
l'arabe à se motiver à fond à passer le
concours et à se dire ben on va aider à
comprendre ce qui se passe ça
m'intéresse. Je veux aller sur le
terrain, je veux faire des notes. Moi je
leur dis, vous savez, soyez faites
attention de pas être désabusé trop vite
parce que parfois il y a ce barrage, je
j'insiste là-dessus sur est-ce que ce
que je suis en train d'écrire va passer
à l'échelon qui lui prend les décisions.
C'est pas le rédacteur qui prend les
décisions, lui donne des éléments qui
doivent alimenter le politique. Mais il
y a cette cette jeunesse et ces ces
jeunes diplomates, ils y croient, ils
veulent. Alors après certains y restent
jusqu'au jusqu'à la fin, d'autres
partent en cours de route parce
qu'effectivement ils se rendent compte
que on on les entend pas beaucoup
insister sur un point dont il faut
mesurer l'impact. Il y a deux systèmes
de recrutement au quor soit c'est l'ENA,
tu tu es bien classé, tu es dans un
endroit où tu peux choisir le qu d'oré
donc tu as une formation de généraliste
qui va partir au qu d'ors ou alors il y
a le cadre Orient. Le cadre orient, ça
veut dire qu' il y a trois zones
géographiques dans lesquelles tu dois
apprendre deux langues locales plus
l'anglais évidemment qui est la langue
et puis ensuite tes épreuves sont centré
sur ta connaissance culturelle de la
région. Bon, la pondération de ces deux
systèmes de recrutement donne évidemment
un avantage énorme au aux gens issus de
l'ENAT. Moi je l'ai dit une fois à
Vedrine, j'ai dit dans un système de
mondialisation, vous devriez tarir le
recrutement par l'ENA pour pas augmenter
le cadre Orient parce que le cadre
Orient, c'est celui qui va vous affecter
un lusophone au Brésil, qui va vous
affiser un japonisant au au à Tokyo et
cetera. Pour te donner un exemple, moi
j'ai un ami qui était probablement le
meilleur japonisant du K d'ors. Il n'a
jamais été affecté au Japon. Donc tu as
bien quelque chose à l'intérieur qui
fait que on te dit "Ah, il a tel grade
?" Ah oui donc il a un poste. Oui mais
c'est un poste de premier conseiller.
Bah c'est pas grave, il va partir au
Nicaragua. Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
C'est aussi cet illogisme de la société
parce que les mecs t'explique que tu oui
mais si tu es japonisant et que tu vas
au Japon, tu vas évidemment soutenir la
teste du Japon. Enfin, je veux dire,
c'est quand même extraordinaire.
C'est-à-dire que par exemple, je prends
l'exemple du Japon, celà je le connais
le mieux. Comme c'est un poste qu'on
veut montrer au Japonais comme
important, on met un mec qui est plutôt
en fin de carrière. Donc un mec qui a
été secrétaire général du K. Mais quand
tu as été secrétaire gural du CU, tu as
plus eu de contact avec le Japon pendant
des années. Tu es même pas japonisant.
Donc tu vois, la logique du système
sociologique est faite de telle manière
que on va pas avoir automatiquement le
meilleur système sur plus. Maintenant,
le système français a cette intelligence
de disposer de l'agence France-Press.
C'est-à-dire que l'agence France Press,
c'est la première la première dépêche
qu'on lit dans une cellule de crise. Et
oui, parce que le type du le journaliste
local, il connaît le sujet, il a des
collaborateurs locaux, il se va
directement sur place, chose que le
diplomate ne peut pas toujours faire
parce que si le diplomate se fait pincer
dans une manife, ça fait un accident
diplomatique. On dit oui quand même ça
il a rien à faire et rappelle-toi
l'affaire Clotil Dryce cette jeune
chercheuse du CNRS qui effectivement
faisait son travail de chercheuse
puisqu'elle allait aux manifestation
elle assistait et puis évidemment elle
revenait à l'ambassade racontait et les
Iraniens ont dit "Ah dans ce cas c'est
une espionne
donc tu vois le le jeu de chacun dans ce
dans cette espèce de comédie de l'ombre
et les diplomates sont pas
obligatoirement les pires dans ce
système. C'est un système d'ensemble
dans lequel effectivement comme tu sais
la la terre est plate et Paris en est le
centre. Et donc tu as à Paris des gens
qui disent "Mais enfin cher ami, je
connais très bien cette situation, je
suis allé passer mes vacances en
Tunisie."
Alors on on va on va une dernière
question sur la mentalité des diplomates
puis on va repasser à notre
Moyen-Orient.
Quand on a vu Emmanuel Macron dire que
l'état profond,
il va falloir quand même se détendre
avec les Russes, est-ce qu'il y a cet
état profond dans le qu d'ors dans la
mentalité des diplomates ? C'est-à-dire
ils ont leur leur vision du monde qui
n'est peut-être pas la même que le la
vision de de notre président et le
président est obligé de leur rappeler
pour qui le diplomat bossent.
Il y a pas une vision qui est dors. Il y
a pas une vision. Pourquoi le le
président est obligé de refaire cette
Non mais ce que ce que le président dit
c'est qu'il y a une France profonde,
c'est-à-dire que c'est pas les élites
qui font la France. Les élites doivent à
certains moment tenir compte du fait que
ils ne sont pas les les gens qui vont
définir la le monde, qui vont définir
les grandes orientations parce que
encore une fois, tu es dans une
démocratie. Donc là, moi à mon avis la
le pays profond, l'exemple le plus
extraordinaire, c'est celui des
États-Unis.
On a été tous les deux dans des systèmes
dans lesquels on avait des contacts avec
les sing américains de la côte est et de
la côte ouest.
Quel type de sing tank ? Comment c'était
quoi les noms ?
Enfin, je vois pouvit être la FRS, ça
pouvait être à la délégation des
affaires stratégiques. Mais enfin, si tu
veux chacun aller aux États-Unis
chercher confirmation de ce qu'il
pensait en allant soit sur les sing
et cetera, enfin le CS, soit on sur la
côte ouest en Californie pour aller voir
la rente. Bon,
et un jour, il y a un sing tank qui me
dit "Regardez nos relations avec les
États-Unis, qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
?" Et effectivement, il avait la Totale,
la CSIS, la rende et cetera. Je lui dis
mais vous n'avez aucun contact avec les
sing républicains, l'American
Foundation, l'American Enterprise et
cetera. C'est cela qui renouvelle la
chose. Donc quand on se dit si tu veux
un pays profond, tu as l'exemple devant
toi des États-Unis où tout le monde
donnait Hillary Clinton vainqueur et on
voit apparaître un type qui est élu par
la Bible belt et qui est élu par la le
Middle West. Mais personne va passer ses
vacances dans le Middle West. Tu vois ce
que je veux dire ? Donc tu vas pas
reprocher au diplomat cette espèce de
comment dire de tradition.
Un pays a une image collective.
Donc et cette image collective, elle se
répercute aussi dans l'esprit des
ministres et des ministres quand on lui
dit "Mais moi, je connais bien les
États-Unis, je suis allé à New York il y
a encore pas longtemps." Il veut pas
prendre en compte cette diversité. Tu
comprends ce que je veux dire ? C'est
donc les diplomates sont un des éléments
du circuit d'information dont le
décideur doit tenir compte. On a fait
par exemple à la maison des sciences de
l'homme il y a quelques temps dans un un
séminaire qui s'appelait Sortir de la
violence, un séminaire de qu'avait fondé
Michel Vivorka et dans laquelle on a
fait le tour de la planète sur les
différents modalités de sortie de crise.
Et puis au bout de 2 ans, je leur ai dit
"Mais si vous savez, vous vous étonnez
vous chercheur que les propositions que
vous formulez parce que vous êtes sur le
terrain, les propositions que vous
formulez ne sont rarement suivies par le
politique." Mais parce que vous ne savez
pas comment fonctionne le politique.
politique, il a son échéance électorale,
son stratégie à long terme, c'estàd sa
réélection et cetera et cetera. Et donc,
on a fait des choses qui ont été
absolument extraordinaire. On a fait
venir Vedrine, Louis Gautier, Julier et
cetera qui sont venus parler sur la
façon dont s'était passé certaines
décisions en situation de crise et si tu
veux tu avais en face de toi des
chercheurs qui ne deun seul coup
recevaient des des douches froides parce
qu'il disaient mais nous finalement à
postérioris on s'est aperçu que c'était
telle source d'information qui nous
avait été utile et que la recherche lire
un bouquin de 600 pages quand on est
dans la crise on n arrive pas tu
comprends donc tuas ces cultures là il
faut aussi les mesurer dans leur mode de
fonctionnement par exemple on a invité
Vedrine
Il y a eu une campagne de de dénigrement
dans la maison des sciences de l'homme
en disant "Comment vous recevez Vedrine
? Mais c'est scandaleux, il a les mains
pleines de sang à cause du Rwanda."
Vedrine a commencé son truc en disant
"Quand j'étais à l'Élysée, moi mon
domaine c'était l'Europe, je m'occupais
pas de l'Afrique." Ah ! Alors d'un seul
coup, tu avais un type dont l'image
était celle du bourreau qui avait
collaboré à une décision à laquelle il
n'avait pas participé. Et encore une
fois, le type est suffisamment
consistant pour se pas mentir sur des
sujets comme cela. Donc tu vois comment
le encore une fois l'imaginaire
collectif peut complètement pervertir le
mode de fonctionnement d'une d'une
situation. On on a on a eu une lecture
sur les diplomates. Maintenant, on va
voir une lecture sur le les
universitaires
qui euh pour certains brassent de l'air
chaud ou sculpte de la fumée sur leur
sur leur champ de d'expertise. Soit ils
ont pas d'expérience de terrain, soit
ils sont ils parlent pas la langue, mais
ils sont toujours là à monter sur leurs
grands chevaux pour dire beaucoup de
choses. Est-ce qu'il y a un pantouflage
et une autocensure chez les
universitaires ?
Est-ce que ces personnes ne se filtrent
pas trop pour pouvoir préserver leur
petit déplacement sur place, préserver
leur petit
Non, est-ce que vous voyez où je vais en
venir ? Bon, on a comme un certain
nombre de chercheurs qui s'expriment,
qui suscitent des réactions, qui font du
buzz, qui ont pas peur de dire ce qu'ils
pensent, même s'ils se font mal voir sur
des questions par exemple sur
l'islamisme. Moi, j'ai en tête quelques
chercheurs qui n'hésitent pas à dire ce
qu'ils pensent et bah comme François
Burga qui est quelqu'un qui euh qui est
souvent éduqué,
bah, il dit beaucoup de choses sur il
dit qu'il faut parler avec les
islamistes, il faut parler avec les
frères musulmans que c'est une
composante de la sociologie des sociétés
dans cette région, qu'on les aime ou
qu'on les aime pas. Ils sont là qu'il
faut parler avec eux. il s'est fait euh
étriper dans des débats publics
vis-à-vis de de personnel politique ou
par des confrères universitaires, mais
il s'expriment, il continue àassablement
à exposer ce qu'ils pensent, il
continuent à se balader dans la région.
Euh l'appareil, je veux dire chez les
universitaires, on aura la même gamme de
de de population qu'on a chez les
diplomates. On va voir des des
universitaires qui diront "Je vais sur
le terrain, je veux aller voir ce qui se
passe et si j'écris des choses qui se
passent pas, je prends le risque de ne
plus avoir du visa pour retourner dans
les pieds en question." Et il y a des
universitaires qui vont dire je fais
attention donc je vais me limiter dans
ma recherche parce que je veux avoir je
veux continue à avoir accès au terrain.
Après ça c'est le choix de chaque
universitaire ou de chaque chercheur par
rapport à son terrain de de recherche.
Et aujourd'hui dans la région c'est vrai
que ça devient de plus en plus difficile
de travailler. Dans quel pays
aujourd'hui un chercheur peut travailler
tranquillement ? Ben ça se réduit comme
pot de chagrin.
Il faut te dire qu'un chercheur a deux
comment dire deux domaines
d'intervention différents. Il y a
évidemment le terrain donc sa liberté de
parole, la façon dont il le dit la et
puis il y a le fait d'être devenir le
conseiller du prince parce que dans le
système français et c'est c'est là une
des principales difficultés, c'est que
le politique et en particulier la
technructure du qu d'orsé n'est pas
obligatoirement prête à accepter que
quelqu'un participe à une décision avec
une légitimité que parfois le directeur
de cabinet ou le conseiller technique
n'a pas.
Non, c'est très important à comprendre
hein parce que alors d' vécu quand même.
Non, mais je te raconterai un épisode
toujours sur le Rwanda. Si tu veux, les
universitaires, ils ont ce défaut de se
parler entre eux. Par exemple, il y en a
un que je connais qui est probablement
le meilleur spécialiste sur les
salafistes. Je lui dis
Farad Rosrocavar. Je lui dis "Mais
Farad, tu ne peux pas penser qu'un homme
politique va lire un bouquin de 600
pages ?" Il me dit "Ouais, mais moi je
suis un chercheur." Mais enfin, arrête,
tu te rends compte de l'intelligence qui
se perd parce que tu ne veux pas te
mettre dans la peau de quelqu'un qui n'a
que tr qui n'a que des réunions de 2
heures et que il faut qu'il lise quelque
chose de très synthétique. Mais lui par
contre, c'est l'exhaustivité qui
prévaut. Bon, donc tu euh ça c'est une
culture, c'est-à-dire la note de bas de
page, c'est fait partie de la culture
des chercheurs. Quand tu regardes du
côté des décideurs, moi j'ai participé
encore une fois, je reviens sur
l'exemple du Rwanda parce que c'est le
plus rigolo. Le le Rwanda, on était dans
les réunions bureau du directeur de
cabinet, on préparait l'opération
turquoise. L'opération turquoise était
une opération militaire extrêmement
sensible puisque il s'agissait
d'intervenir dans une guerre civile,
dans un génocide avec la mission de
d'exfiltrer les Français et puis
évidemment d'essayer de faire de
l'interposition. Bref,
essayer.
Attends, attends, je te termine
l'histoire. Donc, il y avait le le chef
du cabinet militaire, il y avait le
directeur de cabinet, il y avait euh le
le directeur des affaires stratégiques,
il y avait moi, il y avait que des chefs
sauf un mec desit pas un chef mais qui
était le seul à connaître le Rwanda. Et
il était là parce que quelqu'un du
cabinet avait imposé sa présence. Bon,
alors le chef du cabinet militaire dit
"Bon mais l'opération turquoise, on va
se servir de la plateforme de Goma qui
est aux aï et comme ça ça va se déployer
dans le nord et cetera." Bon bah, c'est
de la technique militaire. On dit bon
c'est vous qui savez. Et ce fameux type
intervient en disant "Écoutez, moi je
connais rien en technologie militaire en
technique militaire. Simplement je vous
dis si vous vous déployez dans le nord
il y a plus de toutci. Ils ont été
massacrés. Ils se sont tous réfugiés
dans les colines du sud. Donc vous allez
intervenir et tout le monde va penser
que vous venez une fois de plus soutenir
vos alliés. Mais dans sciences
politiques, tu peux pas tenir compte de
la connerie humaine pour expliquer
certaines décisions. Tu es obligé de
penser que les décideurs sont
rationnels, sinon tu fais pas de science
politique. Or là, on était dans un
exemple classique si tu veux où
l'expertise a servi à empêcher une
catastrophe mais on a vécu alias comme
moi, des tas de situations dans
lesquelles tu te disais mais qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé dans leur tête ?
Agè un exemple ?
Non, j'ai pas d'exemple comme ça.
Non, c'était il y a longtemps. Donc
c'est vrai que j'ai j'ai un peu j'ai un
peu zappé. rappelle-toi sur l'Algérie
par exemple quand tu commences les
années sombres en Algérie,
tu avais trois générations de gens qui
parlaient de l'Algérie.
Oui, c'est vrai. Il avais les
militaires,
ils avaient fait la guerre d'Algérie.
L'Algérie, je connais, j'ai fait la
guerre.
Tu avais les ambassadeurs devenus enfin
les anciens coopérants devenus
ambassadeurs. Je connais l'Algérie, j'ai
fait la coopération là-bas. Et puis tu
avais des mecs qui disaient "Mais
attendez, l'Algérie dont on parle
aujourd'hui n'est plus la même. n'est
plus la même." Et donc tu avais ces
espèces de poids sociologiques où chacun
dans une réunion apporter sa perception
de l'Algérie et effectivement au bout du
compte tu te retrouvais avec des comment
dire des pesanteurs qui faisaient que la
décision au sommet parce que tous ces
gens-là ceux qui avaient fait la guerre
d'Algérie étaient devenus chef et ceux
qui avaient été machin ils étaient
parfois devenus ambassadeurs. Donc tu te
retrouves dans une situation comme
celle-là. Et à l'inverse, je voyais une
fois un colloque en Algérie et alors les
mecs nous disent "Ah, j'étais avec une
fille qui était qui était là aussi pied
noir." Alors les mecs disent "Ah, vous
êtes de chez nous et cetera, bienvenue
et cetera." C'estàd très cordiaux et
cetera. Et la fille qui a 10 ans de
moins que moi ou 15 ans de moins que moi
dit mais elle leur dit mais vous me
dites que je suis d'ici mais moi je suis
arrivé en France en 62 j'avais je sais
pas 7 ou 8 ans. Mes parents ne m'ont
jamais parlé de l'Algérie. C'est-à-dire
ils m'ont toujours, moi je suis une
européenne c'est-à-dire on m'a parlé de
la construction européenne. Et tout à
coup on avait en face de soi des
Algériens qui disaient "Mais enfin
comment il y a des Français qui se
désintéressent de l'Algérie ?" Tu vois
ce que je veux dire ? C ces
perceptions-là sont des perceptions que
tu retrouves dans la société française
et tu vas les retrouver dans tous les
pays du monde.
Euh vous voulez rajouter un mot ? Yes !
Non non je crois pas.
Et on va on va parler de des kurdes du
respect de la parole diplomatique.
Pourquoi ça vous fait rire Agnès ?
Non parce que l'affaire des curdes c'est
vraiment c'est tragique quoi. C'est
tragique.
C'est tragique pourquoi ? Pour la France
ou pour les Kurdes ou pour les deux ?
Pour les Kurdes c'est tragique parce que
c'est une fois de plus je veux dire ce
sont les grands oubliers de l'histoire.
On les traite n'importe comment, on les
utilise et on les jette quoi. Donc c'est
vrai que cette histoire curde
aujourd'hui, je la trouve absolument
terrible, terrible. On n pas personne ne
respecte la parole vis-à-vis des des CD
et on les laisse se débrouiller tout
tout simplement.
Enfin, ça devrait pousser la France à ne
pas fournir de garanties de sécurité.
Et oui, d'abord
si tu veux Trump est un personnage qui a
un peu bouleversé le paysage politique
diplomatique. Bon, moi j'ai pensé que
c'était un bipolaire qui passait d'un
coup d'une séance d'excitation à un truc
mais il y a un copain médecin qui m'a
dit "Non, les bipolaires c'est des
phases longues. Lui c'est des troubles
de la personnalité. C'est du jour sur le
lendemain, il est capable de dire
exactement le contraire. Donc tu vas
faire une ligne diplomatique type comme
ça. Ça mais il a totalement fait voler
en éclat tout. N'oubliez pas que le
première décision qu'il prend en
arrivant à la Maison Blanche, c'est de
ne de retirer la signature des
États-Unis sur la convention de Paris
sur le l'environnement.
Tu c'est pas tu te dis mais attends
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Il était
vraiment chatouillé à ce point-là qu'il
voulait pas imposer aux Américains la
moindre restriction sur la pollution.
Donc ce personnage là je reviens à ce
que je disais tout à l'heure nous ne
connaissons pas les États-Unis. Nous
connaissons certains interlocuteurs aux
États-Unis. La complexité de la société
américaine, ces mécanismes électoraux et
cetera sont des choses sur lesquelles on
ne se penche pas parce qu'on a une
image, une espèce de persistance
rétinienne. Moi, alors du deuxème livre
blanc de la défense, le patron de ce
deuxième livre blanc était Jean-Claude
Mala. Donc il était dans une grand messe
où il y avait tous des gens officiels
qui disaient voilà il c'est comme si
c'est comme ça le poids de la France
pays droit d'homme
pas la question les curdins. D'accord.
Non non mais je reviens là-dessus parce
que si tu veux c'est extrêmement
important. Je disais, on était dans
l'invasion de l'Irak décidé par George
Bouche. Et donc je disais mais est-ce
que il faut introduire dans la réflexion
stratégique le risque américain ? Le
risque américain, on était en 2004 et il
me dit "Vous avez raison mais je peux
pas l'écrire." Et donc quand tu te dis
aujourd'hui avec un type comme Trump, il
t'annonce un jour que bon c'est fini, il
va retirer ses troupes, de toute façon
vous vous démerdez et puis s'il y a des
des djihadistes qui sont libérés, ben
oui, mais enfin c'est vous que ça
concerne et cetera. tu te dis mais
encore une fois la question est-ce que
ça concerne les Kurdes ou est-ce que ça
concerne notre relation aux États-Unis
et notre notre manière de fournir des
garanties de sécurité quand on est dans
le sillage des Américains quand il suit
un mec comme ça qui d'un seul coup
change de direction
il faut arrêter de penser qu'on est un
acteur important dans les crises
encore un peu des mots pour les Kurdes
c'est une faillite de nos diplomates
c'est une faillite de notre armée
pourquoi on les
Non là en l'occurrence c'est quand même
on est la la France et Pierre l'a dit
tout à l'heure on [__] des Américains.
Non, pas [__] des Américains, mais on
est une puissance quand même de 2e rang
et pas de premier rang.
Puissance de moyenne impuissance
de voilà. Donc on va pas tout seul
pouvoir faire quelque chose. Et à partir
du moment où les Américains décident de
se retirer du nord de la de la Syrie et
alors que c'est la zone dans laquelle se
trouvent les Kurdes et que les
Américains sont là en appui des Kurdes
pour les protéger des Turcs qui ne
veulent pas qu'ils soient présents sur
ce territoire. Nous, on a des forces
spéciales qui sont sur place, qui
essayent de faire ce qu'elles peuvent,
mais qui n'ont pas la possibilité toute
seule de pouvoir remplacer les
Américains qui eux partent. Donc notre
le problème il est là, c'est que nous on
je pense qu'on avait pas forcément envie
de laisser les Kurdes en face-àface avec
les Turcs et on avait pas forcément
envie que les Turcs rentrent dans cette
zone et au prix de du de du départ des
Kurdes, mais que tout seul nous les
Français, on n' pas la possibilité de
réagir et de remplacer les Américains.
Donc c'est toujours notre dépendance à
l'égard des des Américains.
Souvenez-vous en 2013 en Syrie lorsqu'il
y a eu la confirmation que les Syriens
avaient utilisé que Bachar Assad avait
utilisé des armes chimiques, nous nous
avions été sur le point de décoller. On
a j'ai fait une interview à l'époque
pour le la revue Confiance Méditerranée
avec le chef d'étatmajor quelques temps
après, il nous a expliqué les avions
français étaient sur le point de
décoller. Là-dessus Obama fait une
déclaration selon laquelle il y va pas
finalement, il veut de l'accord
auparavant du du Congrès. Bah nos avions
bah ils sont repartis, ils sont mis au
garage alors qu'on était sur le point de
décoller. On n pas pu le faire. Donc
dans toute l'affaire, si on maintenant
on parle plus de l'affaire syrienne,
c'est vrai que on a eu une politique qui
a été à chaque fois une politique qui a
été qui s'est mise avec les Américains
et on a été complètement obligé
finalement de suivre la position
américaine et quand il y a eu des
renversements de situation déjà avec
Obama en 2013 et là avec Trump qui
décide de lâcher les Kurdes et ben on se
retrouve comme ça comme de grandes gens
et puis on sait plus quoi faire. Comment
vous comment vous analysez le fait que
un homme Vladimir Poutine maintenant au
21e siècle ramasse toutes les cartes ?
Mais
il est cohérent Poutine. Poutine depuis
le départ qu'est-ce qu'il dit Poutine ?
Il dit "Moi, je vais soutenir Assad."
C'est pas qu'il aime Assad, je crois
qu'il en a strictement rien à faire.
Mais la la Syrie et la Russie ont une
alliance stratégique depuis depuis les
années 50. que euh la Poutine a à cœur
de montrer que lorsqu'il a une alliance
avec un pays, quelle que soit
l'évolution, il reste fidèle à la
différence des Américains qui ont beau
avoir des alliances, peuvent les
dénoncer du jour au lendemain. Et on
peut revenir à l'Arabie Saoudite,
aujourd'hui les Saoudiens sont paniqués
par les Américains se rendant bien
compte qu'ils ont beau eu avoir acheté
des centaines de milliards de dollars
d'armement, les Américains pourraient du
jour au lendemain les lâcher comme ils
ont lâché. Hosni Mubarak en 2011 comme
ils ont lâché Ben Ali, comme ils ont
lâché le chat d'Iran
et que les Saoudiens se rendent compte
qu'ils ont pas forcément fait le bon
choix alors qu'un Poutine qui vient
d'accueillir en grande pompe il y a la
semaine dernière à Riad Poutine
lorsqu'il a une alliance avec la Syrie,
que ce soit à sa père, il continue avec
Assad fils et que même s'il considère
que Assad fils est un couillon, il
continuera à le soutenir parce que ça
fait partie d'une alliance et que c'est
son intérêt de toute façon de le
maintenir. La relation aujourd'hui
Poutine qu'est-ce qu'il fait ? Il a un
Moyen-Orient en face de lui. Il a un
Moyen-Orient avec un Trump dont on sait
absolument pas ce qu'il va décider le
matin ou le soir. Il va changer d'avis.
Mais ce qu'il a annoncé et ce qu'il fait
de toute façon clair et nette, c'est
qu'il se retire des endroits où il n'a
rien à récupérer. Parce qu'on dit que
les Américains se retirent du
Moyen-Orient, il se retirent
effectivement du nord de la Syrie, mais
il serait il retournent en Arabie
Saoudite parce qu'il y a des soldats
américains maintenant qui viennent
s'asseoir en Arabie Saoudite. Donc quand
on parle de retrait américain, il faut
prendre ça avec une certaine qui qui
maintenait une petite division pour
protéger les pétroes parce qu'il veut
pas que le gouvernement de Hassad
récupère le pétrole qui redonnerait en
fait un peu de d'oxygène au gouvernement
de Hassad. Donc si les Américains
choisissent aujourd'hui de laisser
quelques hommes à côté des des puits de
pétrole, c'est pas pour la richesse que
ça représente parce que c'est peinuts
mais c'est pour empêcher le régime de
Hassad récupérer ce pétrole. Ta question
a une dimension géopolitique que moi je
trouve beaucoup plus large si tu veux.
On a vécu après 91 dans un système
unipolaire. C'est-à-dire on a dit bon
maintenant il y a une seule grande
puissance. Les Américains, ils nous ont
sorti la fin de l'histoire, ils nous ont
sorti le clash des civilisations et
cetera.
Et donc en fait une seule fois quand ils
ont déclaré la guerre illégale à l'Irak,
si tu veux, il y a eu un phénomène de
réticence de la France, de l'Allemagne
et de la Russie et cetera sur le fait
que on ne pouvait pas parce qu'on était
dans un système unilatéral décider d'une
guerre totalement illégale en marchant
sur la tête du droit international et
cetera. Bon,
les trois interventions américaines se
sont terminées en notre boudin. En
Afghanistan, on discute avec les
talibans. En Irak, finalement, le régime
ne s'est pas du tout stabilisé. Et puis
en Syrie, finalement, c'est les Russes
qui ramassent les bills. Pourquoi je dis
ça ? Parce que si tu veux, c'est la fin
d'une époque dans laquelle la la comment
dire le les théâtres internationaux se
décidaient à Washington. Aujourd'hui, tu
vois l'apparition d'un acteur russe qui
avec une certaine constance, une
certaine continuité et sans raconter de
grands discours sur les droits de
l'homme finalement joue une continuité.
N'oublie pas que la Syrie est le seul
pays dans lequel les Russes ont une base
maritime quand même he et donc c'est
leur seul accès à la Méditerranée. Et
donc ils ont eu cette constance de
toujours défendre Assad et avec un
argumentaire qui tenait debout puisque
finalement on s'est retrouvé avec l'État
islamique en Syrie. C'est-à-dire que
nous on prétendait défendre l'armée
syrienne libre dans laquelle l'armée
syrienne libre étant elle-même massacrée
par les djihadistes et on se retrouvait
à dire "Ouais mais alors finalement
est-ce qu'on bombarde ? Est-ce qu'on
bombarde pas rappelle-toi au début qu'on
ne voulait pas bombarder l'État
islamique, l'opposition de Hollande en
disant "Oui, mais ça va renforcer
Assad."
Donc si tu veux, quand on est dans ce
genre de situation, c'estàd qu'on a pas
une idée assez ferme et assez constante
de l'objectif qui va être celui de la
France et de l'Europe, ben on se
retrouve dans une politique de suivi. Et
encore une fois, dernière remarque, à
chaque fois qu'on a voulu militariser
les crises, ça a toujours tourné mal.
toujours. C'est-à-dire qu'on a cassé la
Libye, la Syrie, l'Irak et cetera et on
ne reconstruit pas un État qui a qui
sont des États découpés par le
post-colonial et qui n'ont pas
d'homogénéité
nationale. Et donc si tu veux, c'est
bien pour la voix pour gagner des voix
pour se faire réélire genre SarkoZi avec
la Libye mais il n'empêche que derrière,
tu vois bien qu'on laisse une
catastrophe.
Agnès, un petit mot là-dessus. Oui. Non,
c'est vrai que la la l'intervention
militaire n'est en rien une solution à
ce qui se passe et qu'on voit bien que
les interventions militaires ces
derniers temps dans la région ont été
absolument catastrophiques. Ce qui est
dramatique, je crois, et dans le cas de
la Syrie.
Catastrophique pour qui ? Ben pour les
populations concernées.
Ah oui, mais par exemple par les libes
sont quand même euh c'est maintenant le
la Libye c'est quand même un champ de
ruine et avec euh différentes euh
composants de la société libyenne qui
sont tout complètement éclatés qui
n'attendent qu'une chose c'est de
pouvoir espérer avoir une réconciliation
pour euh pour faire démarrer ce pays.
Aujourd'hui, c'est quand même un champ
de ruine cette cette libre
de l'Irak. La la stratégie américaine
dans une guerre comme ça pour démolir
Saddam Hussein, la stratégie américaine
c'est on a la supériorité technologique
donc on casse chez l'adversaire toutes
ses réserves de de munition euh tous ces
ponts, tous ces bois de communication et
cetera, c'est central électrique. Bon
et donc on arrive à la
bien fait euh avec les Serbes ça non ?
Attends attends on termine la guerre et
on explique aux populations qui n'ont
plus ni l'eau, ni l'électricité, ni la
sécurité ni les services minimum qui se
doivent être contents parce qu'ils ont
la démocratie.
Tu comprends bien que le décalage entre
le la méthode militaire et l'objectif
politique est à s'arracher les cheveux
et d'ailleurs
pour vendre nos armes si on les montre
pas.
Mais c'est pas nos armes. La question
c'est de changer la mentalité des
décideurs. Il faut faire comprendre à
des chefs de grande démocratie que c'est
pas on gagne pas une élection simplement
parce qu'on décide de faire la guerre.
Il faut commencer par faire une analyse
politique avant de décider d'envoyer des
militaires. Mais c'est tellement facile
d'envoyer des militaires parce qu'on est
passé dans un temps médiatique,
c'est-à-dire il y a une révolution où il
y a un truc à tel endroit. Ah ! Alors,
cellules de crise, qu'est-ce qu'on fait
? Il faut envoyer des militaires. Bon,
les militaires sont obéissants, ils y
vont. Mais le la ligne de conduite la
ligne de conduite doit être définie par
le politique en se disant est-ce que ça
va peser de quelque manière que ce soit
d'envoyer des militaires sur place ?
Rappelle-toi qu'au début de la guerre en
Youoslavie, on envoie des soldats
français et des anglais convaincus que
de toute façon tout le monde va plier
devant le prestige des armées françaises
et anglaises et on les met sous chapitre
5 ou 6, je sais plus. C'est-à-dire qu'il
n'était même pas armé. Or, il se trouve
en interposition entre des Serbes et des
Croates et des Bosniaques qui passaient
leur temps à se tirer dessus par-dessus
leur tête. Donc, tu vois le décalage,
c'est-à-dire il faut faire une étude,
une analyse politique brève et c'est en
ce sens là que la recherche doit peser
parce que elle accumule une connaissance
qui doit participer de la décision
publique avec les services de
renseignement, qui doré et cetera. Mais
c'est pas comme ça que ça fonctionne. On
va fonctionner sur le temps médiatique.
On la France ne peut pas ne pas. La
double négation est très utile pour ça.
Ouais. Non mais la double négation, le
temps politique, le temps médiatique, je
veux bien mais là on va on va passer on
va on va se poser une question entre
nous à bateau rompu.
Ça ne fonctionne pas les services de
renseignement faut remonter des trucs.
Quand ils sont en état de faire remonter
des trucs intéressants, ils sont pas
écoutés.
Les chercheurs quand ils sont dans un
état de faire remonter des trucs
intéressants, ce qui n'est pas le cas
pour tout le monde, euh ils sont pas
écoutés et vous êtes en train de vous
défausser. sur le politique et donc sur
la population parce que c'est la
population qui vote pour le politique.
Non non, pas du tout, pas du tout. Les
les administrations des différentes
natures dont tu as parlé, y compris les
chercheurs font leur boulot. Queilitez
pas un lieu de rencontre si tu veux dans
lequel ils peuvent échanger simplement,
clairement et cetera. Je vais te citer
un exemple. Quand on montre la
délégation des affaires stratégiques, il
y a un bureau afrique sub-saharienne.
Afrique sub-saharienne. Donc, on avait
des budgets d'études. Donc, évidemment,
ça attirrait pas mal de gens, deux
profils de gens qui sont apparus. Le
premier, c'est les mecs qui disaient "Ah
moi, j'ai été le conseiller de tel
président, je connais bien ce pays." Et
je lui disais "Oui, mais vous savez
quand il y a un coup d'état, en général,
le président c'est le dernier informé,
donc vous m'intéressez pas." Et les
autres, c'étaient les géographes,
c'estàd les mecs qui étaient sur le
terrain et qui disaient "Oui, dans telle
région, il y a tel truc et cetera et
cetera." Bon, c'est cela que j'ai
privilégié. Mais tu te rends bien compte
que tu es cerné par des gens qui sont là
tous pleins de bonne conscience pour
t'expliquer voilà ce que ce que ce
qu'est ce pays. Si j'ai pris l'exemple
des États-Unis, c'est parce que c'est un
pays que nous ne connaissons pas. Parce
que c'est un pays sur lequel on va pas
faire d'investissement. dire attendez,
on va vous payer une étude sur les
États-Unis, ça va pas. Tu vois ce que je
veux dire ?
Et puis il risquerait de mal le prendre.
Ah bah oui, mais en même temps si tu
veux, c'est un objet les États-Unis,
c'est un objet donc un objet de
connaissance. Bon et donc tu te
retrouves si tu veux sur chacun de ces
aires géographiques avec des gens qui
vont se prévaloir d'une expertise encore
une fois toujours sectorielle et dans
lesquels ton exemple sur les les
révolutions arabes, qui peut prévoir une
révolution ? Rappelle-toi Louis X, il
disait "Chef, c'est une révolte." Non,
non, c'est une révolution. Euh et Dieu
sait que la suite a montré que ça en
était une. Donc tu vois la révolution
c'est par nature, l'événement politique
est par nature le système que tu ne peux
pas prévoir. On faisait des études, par
exemple, il y a des rayonnages plein
d'études sur laS en 2025.
Tu as deux systèmes de prospective. Tuas
la prospective tendantielle,
c'est-à-dire on se dit bon, on prend
tous les éléments, on prolonge et on se
dit voilà ce que ça va être en 2025.
Donc on fait une étude sur l'URSS en
2025. Et puis tu as la la prospective de
rupture, c'estàdire tu insistes sur un
des facteurs en te disant et si il se
passe ça à ce moment-là tu développes si
tu veux mais tu n'as pas le temps dans
lequel son ton facteur si c'est celui-là
d'ailleurs, va effectivement déclencher
le bouleversement. Rappelle-toi que
Carrière d'Ancos fait ses bouquins sur
l'empire éclaté en disant l'URSS va
éclater par sa périphérie. Or l'URSS a
éclaté par le centre. Mais elle avait
quand même ce sentiment qu'il y avait
quelque chose qui se passait.
Moi juste pour une anecdote mais j'étais
en Syrie en mai 2010.
Je suis allée me passer une quinzaine de
jours. C'est un pays dans lequel j'avais
vécu 2 ans entre sexe. C'était un un
voyage de vacances organisé par
quelqu'un. Oui non non c'était vraiment
vacances pour ça longtemps que j'avais
pas été en Syrie et pour la petite
histoire je devais réactualiser le guide
vert
donc le guide Michelin Siri qui n'avait
pas été réactualisé depuis très
longtemps.
Vous étiez payé pour ça
parce que c'était Oui, enfin payé c'est
un grand mot mais le billet d'avion a
été payé.
Euh et donc je vais réactualiser le
guide parce qu'on était en plein
développement du tourisme en Syrie.
C'était une des grandes des grandes des
grands projets de de Bachar Elassad.
C'est peut-être un des plus beaux pays
de la région la Syrie. He
laisse-moi finir par la Syrie. C'est mon
pays. C'est pas le gros. Va là-bas comme
Non non mais et j'avais vécu 2 ans en
série entre 82 et 84 que j'étais
étudiante à l'Institut français d'études
arabes de Damas qui était le lieu où
tous les les français qui voulaient
apprendre l'arabe pouvaient aller
passer. Donc c'est un pays que je
connaissais bien et donc c'est comme ça
que je pars pour réactualiser mon guide
Michelin. Il y avait plein de vieilles
maisons de dans la vieille ville de
Damas, d'Alb, même à Holmes qui était en
train d'être restauré pour faire venir
les touristes. Il commençait à y avoir
un petit flux de de touristes et c'était
vraiment une richesse sur laquelle le
régime comptait pour développer le
développer l'économie du du pays. Donc
c'est un pays que je connais bien, dans
lequel j'étais retournée régulièrement
et là ça faisait quand même plusieurs
années que j'avais pas mis les pieds. Et
là j'arrive à Damas et je suis
absolument sidérée parce que je
découvre, c'est-à-dire
une libéralisation économique
complètement débridée, des bagnoles
incroyables dans les rues de DAAS qu'on
avait jamais vu parce que du temps du
père de Bachar Alassad, c'était un
régime socialiste, avait quand même des
règles. Il y avait des dispensaires qui
fonctionnaient bien, l'école
fonctionnait bien, c'est un régime
autoritaire mais avec des des des
services public qui fonctionnait un peu
comme en Irak et comme en Irak, la même
chose.
Et là, tout d'un coup, je voyais des
restaurants qui ouvraient avec toute une
classe qui s'était développée, une
classe avec beaucoup d'argent, de
l'argent qui coulait à flot et en même
temps un exode rural absolument
considérable. Donc les banlieux de Damas
qui gonflaient de Kurdes en particulier
qui quittaient la région de la Jésé donc
la région kurde et qui venait à Damas
parce que il y avait eu plusieurs années
de sécheresse et donc la situation
économique et sociale pour ces
populations était extrêmement difficile.
Donc j'ai fait quand même tout un
circuit en Syrie et avant de partir je
discute avec quelques chercheurs. à
l'époque, c'était François Burga qui
était le directeur du centre à Damas en
disant "Bon ben, c'est vrai que le pays
se modernise, il y a des belles voiture,
ce qui était pas le cas auparavant, il y
a des routes quand même qui s'améliorent
parce qu'ils veulent développer le
tourisme mais on sent quand même qu'il y
a des choses qui vont pas très très
bien, que les inégalités sont quand même
absolument sidérantes, que c'est cet
exode rural provoque des des
bidonvillees quand même à la à la
périphérie en particulier de Damas. On
sent qu'il y a quand même plein de
choses qui vont pas très très très bien.
Et en discutant avec les quelques
chercheurs qui étaient là, on était tous
convaincus de la même chose, à savoir
que ça donnait une apparence comme ça en
se promenant quand on déboule pour la
première fois en Syrie d'un pays qui
fonctionnait avec internet était
disponible absolument partout partout
dans n'importe quel petit bouboui vous
avez internet. Donc une image en
apparence formidable. Quand on
connaissait le pays, ce qui était mon
cas, ce que j'avais vécu entre 82 et 84
et que j'étais retourné régulièrement,
on se disait il y a un moment où ça va
pas tenir et que même si les services de
sécurité sont omniprésents, si tout le
monde est contrôlé, la population est
extrêmement contrôlée et qu'on le
sentait ça quand on connaît un peu, il y
a des choses qu'on qu'on sent qu'on
qu'on perçoit très bien.
Absolument. Et puis la petite bosse qui
envoyait systématiquement dans le jean
de de de personnes en civil qui trompe
pas. Bon, il y a eu plein de choses mais
il faut en cuir,
il faut le voir et parce que on connaît
un peu. Ouais. Et ça c'est des choses
qu'on perçoit mais quand on connaît
donc tout en discutant entre nous, on
tout on le savait très bien que ça
allait exploser. Maintenant de savoir
que ça allait exploser à tel jour, telle
date, ça c'est impossible. Mais tout
tous ces éléments qui ont été écrits,
des articles ont été écrits là-dessus,
donc les éléments, on les a. Après, quel
est le signal que le politique lui va
accepter de de prendre
simulation sur la révolution syrienne
extérieure ?
Stimulation.
Ah, stimulation.
Non, non,
non.
Je
honnêtement,
enfin je je ça je n'y crois pas un
instant. Je n'y crois pas un instant.
Juste une anecdote à propos des guides
de voyage. Là, je dois partir en
Birmanie à la fin du mois de novembre.
Je librairie. Pardon. Vac. Tu as fait
tes petits vaccins ?
Oui, ça y est. les je vais dans une hue,
j'achète les guides de voyage de la
Birmanie, j'en achète deux. Dans les
deux, il y a pas un mot sur les roingia,
pas un. Tu cherches dans l'index, tu
cherches ça. C'est-à-dire qu'une
population qui a généré 700000 réfugiés
au Bangladesh, un des pays les plus
pauvres de la planète,
il y a pas un mot dans le guide de
voyage.
Trop de pétrole chez eux, c'est pour ça
? Non non, c'est pas c'est aussi un
mécanique. Tu vas pas dire vous allez
dans un pays dans lequel il y a eu un
massacre et où 900000 personnes ont
quitté le pays parce que donc voilà, il
faut aussi penser à ça. C'està-dire
toute la manière dont tu vas décrire un
pays, quelle que soit ta fonction dans
une société démocratique, c'est aussi
ton propre intérêt que ce soit le
diplomate, que ce soit le chercheur, que
ce soit et cetera. Le chercheur par
exemple, si tu veux, sa légitimité,
c'est de devenir conseiller du prince.
S'il devient conseiller, non mais
beaucoup si tu veux, se joue beaucoup
parce que il n' veulent pas du tout qui
veulent pas du tout être conseiller du
prince. Il y en a qui disent tous agè
c'est naïve agn
peut-être mais et je crois pas du tout
être naïve et je crois qu'il y a aussi
il faut faire attention à une chose
c'est qu'on se fait on projette des
choses on se fait des représentations
qui n'ont rien à voir avec la réalité on
imagine des choses et moi pour avoir été
pendant des années avec les expat ils
sont toujours dans les mêmes bars à se
boire les mêmes binous ils sont on les
voit les expatou mais bien sûr que vous
allez toujours trouver des expates qui
vont aller dans le même café le même
restaurant et qui vivent entre eux mais
pas tous
comme les diplomates. Il y en a qui vont
toujours dans les mêmes salons avec les
mêmes interlocuteurs qui se refilent de
génération en génération. Je les ai vu,
je les ai observé en Égypte en
particulier, mais il y a aussi d'autres
chercheurs, il y a d'autres diplomates
qui conçoivent
pas toujours et qui arrivent et qui font
leur bonhomme de chemin, qui arrivent
quand même à écrire ce qu'ils ont à
écrire en faisant attention parce qu'ils
ont envie de continuer, parce qu'ils
sont passionnés mais qui font et qui
écout pourquoi faut faire attention
quand on a un intellectuel opérationnel
avec du renseignement première main.
Moi, je vais aller jusqu'au bout parce
que vous les certains pensent que je
suis naïve, je suis pas naïve. Moi je
suis réaliste. Moi j'ai travaillé et on
a travaillé ensemble avec avec Pierre. À
un moment j'ai constaté j'ai constaté
que moi, en tant que responsable du
bureau que bondearabe et persant, là où
j'étais, je n'arrivais pas à faire
exactement ce que je voulais. Je suis
partie,
je moi ça a été mon choix. D'autres sont
restés et donc c'est pour ça que je suis
pas naïve. Donc il y a deux types de
chercheurs. Il y a ceux qui sont comme
vous. Je suis désolé courageuse et les
avaleurs de sabre.
Non, chacun fait ce qu'il a envie en
fonction de ses attentes et de ce qu'il
estime pouvoir faire. Au ministère, moi
il m'est arrivé une fois où je voulais
partir en mission en Syrie, tu t'en
souviens très bien et le conseiller du
ministre, je ne donnerai pas de nom, m'a
dit "Il est hors de question d'aller en
Syrie". Et je dis "Pourquoi ?" C'était
après la première guerre du golf. Il me
dit parce que le ministre est très amis
avec les maronites libanais et donc
aller en Syrie qui étaient les ennemis.
Il fallait pas que j'y aille. Bon donc
j'ai eu deux trois trucs comme ça et ben
je je suis partie et je suis allée faire
autre chose. Mais ça ça a été mon choix
et je pouvais décider de rester dans la
boutique en me disant de toute façon en
restant je peux continuer à faire des
choses. Après chacun chacun fait son
choix. C'est pas une question de naïveté
ou autre. Faut être faut être
certainement
que raconte Agnès si tu veux est très
caractéristique du fait que tu peux
avoir une connaissance qui est en
contradiction avec une hiérarchie.
Pour beaucoup de gens, notamment ceux
qui sont diplômés des grandes écoles, la
connaissance, l'expertise vient avec le
diplôme. Ça peut ne pas avoir de rapport
du tout, mais ça veut dire que tu es
dans un cabinet de gens qui tout à coup
pensent qu'ils ont il y a eu une
mutation génétique et donc ils ont la
connaissance et ce que tu vas leur dire
qui peut leur déplaire va se heurter au
fait qu'ils ont le pouvoir hiérarchique.
C'est ça le dysfonctionnement. Quand je
te dis le fait de Prunier qui était dans
la salle ou se décider quelque chose, il
aurait pas dû être là. Tu comprends ce
que je veux dire ? Donc il faut trouver
un système français dans lequel
effectivement l'expertise aide à la
décision publique. Ça suppose que les
chercheurs eux-mêmes mettent dans une
forme consommable des années de
connaissance et que ils aient une
certaine liberté de parole et que tu es
pas autour de du ministre des gens qui
disent "Oui mais enfin ce ce type là
attention, il est dangereux, il est il
est il explique qu'il faut parler avec
les islamistes." Moi une fois j'ai
assisté à une réunion d'ambassadeur
faut leur parler aux islamistes ou pas ?
Attends attends, je te raconte
l'histoire. réunion d'ambassadeur à fin
août une des tables ronde sur le monde
arabe, l'islam politique c'était il y a
une vingtaine d'années. Euh donc tous
les ambassadeurs qui étaient en poste
dans dans le monde araboom musulmans
racon quel était l'islam politique
qu'ils avaient à gérer et cetera. Bon le
ministre entre, tout le monde se lève,
c'est le ministre. Alors le ministre dit
"Messieur, asseyez-vous, asseyez-vous,
votre table ronde est évidemment la plus
importante de toutes celle qui se passe
aujourd'hui. Je vais donner mon
sentiment. On peut pas parler avec ces
gens-là.
Tu es ambassadeur ? Tu as compris que
l'instruction c'est de toute façon qu'il
faut pas que tu fasses remonter. Mais
quand il est reparti le ministre, le typ
l'ambassadeur qui était en train de
parler a dit oui la position du ministre
est très intéressante toutefois dans mon
pays et craqu il a recommencé à parler
de sa connaissance mais pas de ce qu'il
allait écrire dans son télégram.
Donc les islamistes faut leur parler.
Euh comment vous prenez en tant que
chercheuse euh ce qui se passe
maintenant en France avec l'histoire du
voile, de la revendication politique de
l'islam, de de ces choses-là ?
Moi, je suis exaspérée par ce débat sur
le voile. Je trouve qu'on en fait
beaucoup trop, que plus on en parle,
plus on exacerbe les positions des de
toutes parts et qu'on en fait un objet
qui à mon avis n'a pas lieu d'être. Et
je pense que on a un arsenal juridique,
on a des règles qui existent en France.
On n pas besoin à chaque fois de
remettre ce débat sur le sur le sur le
tapis.
On a des règles, on les applique, on les
applique s'il y a besoin, si ça
correspond aux lois qui ont été votées.
Mais à chaque fois qu'il y a quelque
chose, on dit on va refaire une loi, on
va refaire un truc. Et les femmes, elles
ont pas le droit, elles ont le droit,
elles ont d'abord qu'on leur foute la
paix dans le respect des règles de la
République, dans le respect des règles
de la laïcité, mais qu'on arrête de
faire à chaque fois ce ce buzz autour de
de de la du fait que certaines femmes
portent le voile. Je trouve qu'on on le
rajoute et on les pousse et au lieu de
de
il y a voil et voil là,
évidemment, il y a voile et voile. Je
parle pas de la Bourka, il s'agit pas
mais la le dernier truc sur les des
mères qui ont un foulard sur la tête qui
veulent accompagner les enfants en
sortie à l'école. Alors moi j'ai pas vu
toutes les tous les détails. Si les
femmes complètement avec la bourka,
évidemment que c'est hors de question,
mais des femmes qui ont juste un foulard
sur la tête qui veulent accompagner
leurs enfants, euh je crois qu'il y a un
moment il faut arrêter de de son habillé
tout en noir. Bon, si elles sont
habillées tout en noir, mais elles ont
elles ont pas le la grille, mais elles
sont habillées j tout en noir jusqu'en
bas des pieds, c'est Oui.
Non, tout en noir, c'est vrai que s'il y
a vraiment le côté vraiment protection
enfin ou enfin se camoufler derrière de
la vraiment le truc tout noir de la tête
au pied, c'est insupportable mais il y a
beaucoup d'autres femmes simplement ont
un foulard sur la tête et on les embête
avec ça. Je crois qu'il y a mo il faut
qu'on se faut faut se calmer la vo
marché
quand on voit au marché de Nî parce que
ça c'est une expérience personnelle
quand je vois au marché de Nî
de elle devait être en 6 ou 7 ans avec
de de pied en cap c'est normal c'est pas
normal
moi ça me correspond pas et je ne
supporte pas de voir ça je supporte pas
moi Agnèalois de voir ça c'est évident
que je le supporte pas que il y a une
loi qui va s'appliquer pour empêcher
cette gamine ou alors qu'est-ce qu'on
fait. Mais
moi je si tu veux le le débat sur le
voile est porteur de plusieurs
ambiguïés. D'abord le fait que la
République n'a cessé de reculer. Je
travaille en ce moment sur les
entreprises hein.
Diversion médiatique ou pas ?
Pardon ?
C'est une diversion médiatique.
Non pas du tout.
Parce que à chaque fois qu'il y a des
problèmes de chômage, à chaque fois
qu'il y a des problèmes de syndicat, à
chaque fois qu'il y a des problèmes de
renseignement, hop le sujet du voile qui
réapparaît. Non non, la stratégie des
salafistes, c'est une stratégie du pas à
pas. On le constate dans les
entreprises, c'est-à-dire on commence
par dire on veut l'heure des prières
puis après on veut transformer la le la
cantine pour faire de la du halal. Par
exemple, il y a une entreprise, je crois
que c'était Air France où il y a un
petit mec pour être tranquille si tu
veux, il a servi que de la nourriture à
l'al. Alors quand la direction a pris
ça, si tu veux, ils ont dit "Mais
attendez, oh il y a pas que des
musulmans." Bon donc on est face à une
stratégie du pas à pas qui fait qu'à
chaque fois l'autorité hiérarchique,
qu'elle soit dans l'entreprise ou
qu'elle soit dans le politique, en est à
se demander mais finalement est-ce
acceptable, n'est-ce pas acceptable ? Et
cetera. Le débat sur le voile, il est
futile par rapport à ce qui se passe
ailleurs. C'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui,
tu vas avoir dans des entreprises des
mecs qui refusent de serrer la main des
femmes, d'être sous l'autorité d'une
femme, de prendre de la monnaie quand
elle vient dans le d'une femme et de se
mettre un gant pour ça. Dans une société
où on plaide pour l'égalité homme-femme,
tu te rends bien compte qu'il y a une
espèce de contradiction extraordinaire
entre ce qu'on va accepter sous prétexte
que c'est de la culture religieuse, de
la liberté de conscience, ils appellent
ça et le fait qu'on plaide en même temps
pour qu'il y ait une égalité avec les
femmes. Moi ma position est très simple
sur le sujet. Le Coran n'impose que cinq
devoirs aux musulmans. Cinq pas plus. Le
pélerinage, la profession de foi, la
zacat et cetera. Le voile, il y a un mec
qui s'appelle Mekel, ça fait 10 ans
qu'il travaille sur le Coran. Il dit "Je
cherche toujours la sourate qui impose
de voiler les femmes." Donc on est bien
dans quelque chose qui est une
revendication de nature communautaire,
politico-communautaire. Et donc, si tu
avais une position claire en disant
"Écoutez, l'islam français, le CFCM est
là pour le définir. Vous nous dites
quelles sont les règles qu'il faut
auxquelles la République doit s'adapter
?" Par exemple, est-ce qu'on peut
additionner les RTT aux vacances pour
que le mec puisse faire un pèlerinage à
la mec dans de bonnes conditions ? Bon,
même remarque si tu veux plus
extraordinaire, il y a des entreprises
qui vendent du pèlerinage à la mec mais
tu sais que tout est conditionné par le
nombre de visas délivrés par l'Arabie
Saoudite. Donc d'un moment l'Arabie
Saoudite coupe et les mecs ont ont dég
engagé de l'argent auprès d'agence pour
aller faire le pèlerinage. Donc ils
perdent leur pognon. Et tu te retrouves
avec un islamiste chevelu qui dit "Mais
il faut appliquer le droit de la
consommation français."
Je dis mais pourquoi il y a pas il y a
rien dans la charia sur le fait que le
consommateur sur le droit de la
consommation. Tu vois ce que je veux
dire ? Le type il est dans un système
totalitaire où il te dit bon et puis
quand il se trouve en porte à fond, il
dit mais il faut que la France impose le
droit de la consommation française. Donc
si tu veux si tu continues à faire du
flou évidemment Agnas a raison toutes
les femmes qui ont des voiles sur la
tête c'est pas des terroristes. C'est
devenu une espèce de d'apparat si tu
veux en disant mais je suis musulmane et
j'ai pas de raison d'être d'avoir honte
d'être musulmane. Donc ça n'est plus le
débat. Le débat, il se situe ailleurs
dans les entreprises. Quand une
entreprise est obligée d'interrompre sa
chaîne parce que les mecs ont imposé
qu'il y a le temps de la prière, chose
vécu, tu te dis mais oh, on va où ? La
seule entreprise qui impose une charte
de la laïcité à au recrutement est dans
l'illégalité.
Alors, tu te dis mais où est-ce qu'on va
Agnès un mot ?
Non, je suis pas essentiel.
Euh une question d'internet que je vais
compléter après.
Alors la formule la France n'a pas
d'amis, elle n'a que des intérêts.
N'est-elle pas un aveu du fait que nos
politiques se prostituent ? Et moi, je
rajouterai à sa phrase : "Un
fonctionnaire, ça démissionne ou ça
ferme sa gueule ?
Adè !
Mais non, mais un fonctionnaire, il peut
il a quand même une marge de manœuvre.
Je
la porte la porte et le bout du tapis.
Non mais je trouve que on peut pas être
dans un truc tout blanc tout noir et je
trouve que la discussion amène en fait à
des positions c'est tout blanc ou c'est
tout noir. On n'est pas dans du tout
blanc.
Ça vous êtes là pour nuancer.
On n'est pas là dans du tout blanc ou du
tout noir. C'est dire chacun a sa marge
de manœuvre. Chacun peut l'utiliser.
En terme de résultat la marge de
manœuvre que chacun utilise ça nous
emmène nous. On passe pour des guignoles
au Moyen-Orient. On place des on passe
pour des guignoles dans la sature
méditerranéenne, on passe pour des
guignoles un peu partout dans le monde
et on continue de payer nos impôts.
Parce qu'il faut faut le rappeler, un
diplomate c'est grassement payé
quand il est en poste quand il est ici
il est payé il est payé il est payé
normalement comme les autres
fonctionnaires. Donc il a une
contradiction budgétaire structurelle
c'est qu'un diplomate quand il est à
Paris n'a quasiment pas de prix mais
quand il est en poste si tu veux il
double ou il triple son salaire et il
n'est imposé que sur la part française.
Bon alors ça aboutit à quoi ? Ça aboutit
au fait que le réseau coûte cher parce
que tous les mecs qui sont des expatriés
coûtent beaucoup de pognon et il y a
plus d'argent pour la coopération,
c'est-à-dire pour des actions qui
ciblent des locaux qu'on veut faire
venir. Système angloaxon complètement
différent. Les mecs touchent le même
salaire quand ils sont en poste. Ils ont
droit simplement à l'appartement et la
voiture en plus. Mais si tu veux, le
réseau il a un coût constant et donc tu
as de l'argent pour faire venir des
étrangers que tu vas faire venir dans
ton système. Donc le système français,
c'est ce qu'avait essayé de faire ville
peinte si tu veux un moment en réduisant
les avantages des diplomates, ce qui
avait fait éidemment fait des cris
d'orfis parce que comme encore une fois
les gens faut quand même penser que la
femme doit suivre, que les enfants
doivent suivre, que la scolarité et la
vie conditions de vie de la famille sont
quand même compliquées donc ils aient
droit à une espèce de compensation mais
pas le système totalement
disproportionné ou abouti à fait à
entretenir le réseau plutôt que les
actions.
On va parler un peu de l'Iran. Hm hm.
Euh l'Iran qui laisse d'ailleurs qui est
très contente que les Kurdes n'aient pas
d'accès à la mer. Euh que les Turcs
aussi fassent un peu le ménage pour eux.
Non. L'Iran. L'Iran, comment l'Iran se
positionne avec les Kurdes ?
Bah le les Iraniens ont eux-mêmes une
population kurde sur leur territoire
parce que les Kurdes sont répartis sur
quatre pays, la Turquie, la Syrie,
l'Irak et l'Iran. Euh les Iraniens
n'aiment pas la revendication kurde
comme ils n'aiment aucune revendication
de minorité parce qu'ils sont pour
l'intégrité du territoire et donc pour
un seul peuple iranien quels que soient
les appartenances. Donc il y a il y a un
discours qui est assez clair de la part
des Iraniens vis-à-vis des Kurdes, donc
vis-à-vis de leurs propres Kurdes.
Ceci dit, je trouve que dans le retrait
américain du nord de la Syrie, de la
région kurde, c'est plutôt un cadeau
finalement que les Américains font aux
Iraniens puisque ça donne une légitimité
à ce fameux corridor dont on parle
beaucoup de couloir que les Iraniens
veulent mettre en place, qui leur permet
d'aller de Terra en passant par Bagdad,
par la Syrie et qui conduit au Liban
pour soutenir le Hizbola qui est donc le
parti cheit allié de l'Iran dans cette
région. Donc la décision américaine
finalement arrive aboutit à, me
semble-t-il dans tous les cas à une
espèce de cadeau qui est fait par les
Américains à à l'Iran. C'est vrai que
les Iraniens eux sont plutôt en Syrie
dans la zone de Damas et plutôt dans la
zone qui est proche euh de du Liban.
Donc c'est plutôt ça la zone qui les
intéresse. Donc ils sont moins concernés
par cette opération qui se passe au nord
de la Syrie en dehors de cet accès de ce
couloir qui peut les intéresser. Et on
voit bien que là dans la question kurde
nord de la Syrie, c'est beaucoup plus
une question entre les Turcs et les
Russes vis-à-vis des Kurdes et du
gouvernement de Hassad
iraniens sont quand même beaucoup plus
en retrait.
Pierre,
il faut pas penser
moi j'étais historien si tu veux puis
ensuite quand j'ai passé les NAP à des
décision publique et je me suis rendu
compte de l'irrationalité de certaines
décisions et combien l'historien passe
derrière pour donner de la rationalité.
Bon et là le cas de Trump si tu veux on
le vit un candur nature. Ce type d'un
seul coup décide queil va non il dit au
turc allez-y rentrerleur dans le et puis
ensuite le lendemain quand devant les
réactions internationales dit non non
mais attention il faut les retenir ces
gens-là moi donc on est face à une
situation dans laquelle après on va
faire de la reconstitution en disant oui
mais en fait il a dit ça c'est qu'il va
faire ça et cetera non il y a aussi des
gens qui sont d'une totale ignorance qui
vont décider parce qu'ils sont
fondamentalement américains que ils
connaissent le monde. rappelle-toi quand
même que George Bush était un type qui
n'était allé qu'une seule fois au
Mexique quand il était étudiant et il
était l'homme le plus puissant de la
planète. Nous, on fait 400 km, on
traverse six frontières ou sep
frontières. Aux États-Unis, tu fais 2000
km, tu traverses pas de frontière. Et
donc cette différence de culture, si tu
veux, est absolument essentielle. Moi,
une fois, j'ai été invité par un un
single tank américain. Alors, tu sais,
c'est ce système s'appelle
ça veut dire quoi ? Tu payé le billet
d'avion, l'hôtel est tout le tr. Ouais,
c'est ça. L'American Foundation, je sais
plus comment elle s'appeler. Enfin bref.
Et donc ils nous font des entretiens au
département d'État, au Pentagone et
cetera, des intellectuels américains et
cetera. Et puis c'était l'époque de
George Bouche. Et à la fin, il nous
demande effectivement qu'est-ce que vous
avez pensé de tout ça ? Et moi, je leur
ai dit, écoutez, la prochaine fois que
vous avez une un candidat à l'élection
présidentielle, exigez de lui qu'il ait
un passeport usager avec au moins deux
visas tamponnés.
Les mecs comprenaient pas ce que je
voulais leur dire, mais parce que pour
eux, c'était une fonction de
démonstration. Donc si tu es admis à
faire une conférence à la rand, tu es
devenu un grand penseur international.
Tu comprends ce que je veux dire ? Agn
qui se marquè pas d'accord. Bah si je
suis complètement d'accord avec ça et
c'est vrai que c'est ahurissant de moi
je me rappelle l'affaire de avant
l'invasion américaine de l'Irak
de l'Irak
2003 où les Américains en fait avaient
mis en en valeur un irakien Ahmed
Shalabi. Je te souviens ? Et Ahmed
Shalabi était un opposant euh irakien
shahit euh qui vivait entre Londres, les
États-Unis, qui avait une fortune
personnelle colossal. Je sais pas
comment il je me souviens plus comment
il l'avait enfin bon peu importe. Et en
fait Ahmed Shalabi avait vendu à
l'administration américaine à l'époque
le fait que Saddam Hussein allait tomber
et que lui était l'homme providentiel
qui allait pouvoir diriger l'Irak. Comme
il était shahit, c'était très bien
puisque la majorité du pays étant
shahit, les Américains voulant faire des
élections, c'était forcément une les
cheit arrivera en tête et donc lui Ahmed
Shalabi serait le prochain président de
la République et les Américains enfin
l'administration alors je sais pas
laquelle parce qu'il y a quand même là
aussi il y a quand même des gens
compétents aux États-Unis hein dans les
dans les centres de recherche. Et du
coup Ahmed Shalabi est rentré en Irak
sur le char américain. Évidemment, il a
été dégommé tout de suite parce que les
Irakiens lui ont craché dessus en disant
"Mais tu as vécu depuis des années aux
États-Unis et à Londres, c'est pas toi
maintenant qui va être l'homme
providentiel en Irak." Et les Américains
avaient absolument tout construit sur
Ahmed Shalabi qui leur avait vendu le
fait que il connaissait le pays parce
qu'il était irakien alors qu'il était
complètement déconnecté de ce pays
depuis des années des années puisqu'il
était parti et que toute la stratégie
américaine s'est évidemment écrôlée
parce qu'elle avait été bâtie sur cet
homme qui leur avait vendu n'importe
quoi. Et ce qui est quand même très
surprenant dans ce système américain,
c'est que il y avait pas eu d'autres
voies qui s'étaient élevées pour dire
mais c'est peut-être un peu peut-être
faut qu'on réfléchisse
différemment. mê travers sans traverser
l'Atlantique. Rappelle-toi le rôle joué
par BHL dans la crise sy libne. Il
revient, il dit à Sarkozi, je les ai
alors il a payé sa poche he parce qu'il
a l'avantage d'avoir quelques moyens
personnels. Il arrive en en Libye par
l'Égypte et il rencontre un mec de
l'opposition. Il revient voir Sarkozi,
il dit "Il faut les aider. Je les ai vu,
c'est les démocrates, je connais le
nouveau Massou." C'est-à-dire, il se
sert de la référence afghane. Massou,
c'était quand même le mec qui avait tiré
sur Kabou après le départ des Russes
directement sur certains quartiers. Donc
c'était pas le démocrate ancien élève du
lycée français mais le référentiel de
l'intellectuel qui va s'adresser aux
politiques en disant là il y a un bon
coup à jouer, j'ai les clés politiques.
Tu te dis mais les types qui ont dû
entendre ça dans le système du quorsé
ils ont ils ont dû sauter au plafond.
Ils ont sauté au plafond.
Ils ont sauté au plafond. Donc tu vois
ce que je veux dire le restant
non mais qu'est-ce qu'ils peuvent faire
? Je veux dire honnêtement face à
si BHL va voir Sarkozy en disant c'est
comme ça et que Sarkozy a envie de
l'écouter. Sarkozy a envie de l'écouter.
Qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous faites
? Il y a un moment d'ailleurs quand BHL
a voulu faire la même chose avec la
Syrie, avec les Syriens, les les les
l'opposition syrienne a dit à Bchel on
ne veut pas de vous, dégagez, on ne veut
pas de vous parce qu'il voulait pas
effectivement que la même chose se passe
avec la Syrie. Donc les l'opposition
syrienne a tiré les leçons de
l'opération libne.
Donc Agnès, vous confirmez que Bchel
était un très mauvais ministre des
affaires étrangères.
Ah pour moi c'est une calamité. Oui
mais non mais c'est ce genre de
personnalité médiatique. Je t'ai cité
l'exemple de Hadler avec le son article
sur le Cachogi. Tu as dans le paysage
français des gens qui sont des
inoxydables. BHL a deux fois résolu la
crise afghane. Deux fois dans sa
chronique du point. Deux fois. Il a dit
voilà comment il faut faire. Bon il est
tellement sûr de lui que moi dans la
fabrication de l'ennemie, j'avais
proposé que les Américains envoient
Stalon et que nous on envoie BHL en
Afghanistan puisque Stalon à lui tout
seul il aurait tué tous les mjahidines
et puis BHL aurait réglé la question. Tu
as dans chacun des pays des espèces de
codes de fonctionnement qui sont loin de
la rationalité du terrain avec des
systèmes qui essayent d'y résister mais
quand le chef a décidé, ben tu es
républicain. Le chef a décidé que donc
on y va. Et ça aussi il faut quand même
le rendre compte. Tu vas pas d'un seul
coup voir toute la population. On n'est
pas dans la situation de la France de la
les États-Unis au Vietnam où tu avais eu
des vagues de démission dans
l'administration américaine de gens qui
dénonçaient si tu veux la politique de
Nixon qui était le bombardement sur le
nord Vietnam et cetera. On n' pas ce
genre de phénomène. Donc il faut pas
faire porter aux échelons intermédiaires
si tu veux encore une fois ce qui est de
la responsabilité soit des directeurs,
soit du du politique.
Un petit mot, on on on on me demande de
parler des Arméniens. Vous avez un mot
sur les Arméniens ?
Non, là je pas dire
écoute, l'Arménie est un pays qui se
vide. C'est un pays qui se vide parce
que effectivement il est enclavé
complètement. Il a réussi à avoir des
mauvaises relations avec tout le monde,
sauf avec les Turcs. C'est quand même un
peu paradoxal. il a réussi à avoir des
mauvaises relations avec l'Azerbaïdjan
après une guerre si tu veux qui lui a
permis de conquérer une partie de
l'Azerbaïdjan. Donc un pays si tu veux
qui est dans un état de comment dire
d'enclavement, il devrait avoir des
relations à peu près correctes avec son
environnement. Or il y a une espèce de
rémanence de du génocide en disant il
faut rappeler le génocide et cetera. Ça
c'est un problème si tu veux qui
pervertit considérablement l'analyse
politique. Le processus de la
victimisation
est un processus politique essentiel
pour avoir l'accès aux médias, à la
classe politique et cetera. On le voit
avec les musulmans. Aujourd'hui, tu as
un collectif contre l'islamophobie en
France qui t'explique que les musulmans
sont maltraités en France. Moi, en 2014,
je fais un rapport sur quelle politique
de contreradicalisation en France.
C'était le seul qui existait à ce
moment-là puisqu'il y en avait un qui
était fait par un préfet mais il était
classé secret défense qui est quand même
une certaine manière de d'ouvrir un
débat public. Bon et donc je fais ce
rapport et je téléphone au collectif
contre l'islamophobie en France en
disant je voudrais vous rencontrer parce
que je travaille sur la radicalisation,
je voudrais vous votre sentiment. Je
tombe sur la la fille qui était le porte
qui était chargée des relations avec la
presse qui est une convertie. Elle me
dit "Ah non, nous ça nous concerne pas
la radicalisation. Nous seuls nous
concerne les actes islamophobes." Ah
j'ai dit c'est marrant quand je parle
avec vous, j'ai l'impression de parler
avec le CRIF. moment de silence, je sais
pas pourquoi. Et puis elle me dit "Oui,
non, en fait c'est les actes
islamophobes et cetera et cetera." J'ai
dis "Mais quand vous avez un juif
radical et un musulman intégriste qui se
tape sur la gueule, comment fait-on ?
C'est de l'islamophobie ou c'est de
l'antisémitisme ?" C'est le premier des
deux qui déclare qui a qui a gagné et je
sais pas pourquoi elle a raccroché. Il y
a dans le paysage ce collectif qui est
absolument odieux. Quand le père Amel a
été égorgé dans son église, ils ont fait
un communiqué qu'ils ont ensuite retiré,
mais moi je l'ai gardé sur le thème :
"Nous sommes contre toutes les formes de
violence, mais attention à la montée des
actes islamophobes. Il y avait un prêtre
qui avait été égorgé dans une église."
Tu te rends compte ? Ces gens-là, ils
jouent sur la corde de la victimisation.
Le musulman ne peut être que victime par
nature et tu c'est pas le seul domaine.
Tu vois bien aussi qu'à les gardes
d'Israël, si tu critiques Israël, c'est
que tu dois être antisémite. Et si tu
dis aux Arméniens, "Arrêtez peut-être un
peu avec le génocide parce que voter une
loi sur la Turquie." Si demain la
Turquie adopte une loi en disant "En
Algérie les français se sont comportés
comme des génocideurs,
tu vois ce que je veux dire ? La porte
que tu ouvres avec ce genre de choses.
Donc ces lobby victimaires si tu veux
sont des des acteurs de la vie politique
qui font que si tu fais un petit
discours pour leur caresser un peu dans
le sens du poil, ben tu tu ramasses des
voix. Rappelle-toi le nombre de mairies
qui ont préféré négocier avec des
salafistes en se disant "Mais au moins
je capte quelques voix et cetera."
Agnè.
Oui. Non, c'est vrai qu'il faut
absolument sortir de ce registre de la
de la victimisation. Ça, je pense que
c'est le pire des registres et qui
empêche absolument en plus toute
réflexion, je veux dire qui bloque
absolument toute possibilité de faire
quoi que ce soit. Donc ça c'est quelque
chose qui me me paraît très très
dangereux.
Alors autre question qui va être une
synthèse de beaucoup de questions que je
vois passer devant mon écran. Est-ce
qu'on va déclarer la guerre à l'Iran ?
Est-ce que va y avoir une guerre avec
l'Iran ? Est-ce que l'Iran est mise sous
pression ? Est-ce que c'est de la de
l'intoxe ? Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Est-ce qu'on va vers un conflit vers
l'Iran ? Moi, j'y crois pas au conflit
avec l'Iran. C'est vrai que le l'Iran
est un pays qui est complètement sous
pression, ça c'est clair. Les pressions
économiques imposées par les Américains
sont catastrophiques. Que l'Europe
ce qui ne sert à rien d'ailleurs.
Ben ça ça appauvrit la population. Moi,
j'étais en Iran il y a 3 mois. la
population tire vraiment la langue et ça
c'est catastrophique. Alors le calcul
américain c'est évidemment que la
population se révolte contre le régime
ce que je ne crois pas parce que je
pense que le le la population n'a aucune
envie de faire ce cadeau aux Américains.
Oui, je crois que ça enfin je suis pas
sûr du tout que ça puisse marcher.
Se faire libaniser. Ce qui est
dramatique dans l'affaire iranienne à
mon sens, c'est que l'Europe n'a été n'a
pas été en mesure de mettre en place le
mécanisme qu'elle avait promis aux
Iranien en expliquant que effectivement
il y avait pas de raison d'appliquer les
sanctions puisque les les Iraniens sont
restés dans l'accord, ce sont les
Américains qui sont sortis de l'accord,
c'est pas l'inverse quand même, mais que
les Européens ont été incapables de
respecter leur leur engagement. Donc
c'est bien ça que d'ailleurs les
Iraniens nous reprochent à longueur de
discussion et à juste titre
qui se tourne effectivement vers les
Russes, vers les Chinois surtout. Euh
donc la la population est complètement
mise sous pression de façon absolument
catastrophique. Et la dernière fois que
j'avais été en Iran, les Iraniens
espéraient encore que Trump ne serait
pas réélu. Donc il nous disait si Trump
n'est pas réélu, on a de quoi tenir
jusqu'à la l'élection américaine.
Erreur stratégique parce que Trump va
risque d'être élu. Mais entre-temps,
en ayant discuté à nouveau avec les
Iraniens, maintenant ils ont intégré
dans leur réflexion que Trump pouvait
être réélu et que donc il faut mettre en
place un système pour tenir ben plus
longtemps que ce qu'ils avaient prévu à
savoir la l'année prochaine.
Donc l'Iran essaie effectivement
maintenant de d'adopter les les moyens
dont elle dispose, enfin dont ce pays
dispose en en utilisant des leviers sur
d'autres terrains pour montrer que
l'Iran ne se laissera pas faire. Et nous
moi les Iraniens m'avaient dit
clairement à l'époque de toute façon
quelle année ça ? Bah là, il y a il y a
il y a 3 4 mois en disant de toute
façon, si les Américains continuent avec
les pressions et que les Saoudiens
continue dans cette voie-là pour nous
c'est une déclaration de guerre et donc
on ne se laissera pas faire. Voilà,
le l'affaire de du bombardement des
sites pétroliers saoudiens est très
intéressante parce que
bombardement, bombardement,
enfin peu importe, quel que soit le
vecteur, je m'en fous que ce soit un
missile de croisière, que soit autre
chose, peu importe.
de
ce qui est intéressant c'est que si tu
veux les Iraniens ont fait comprendre
par amis interposé ou directement qu'il
ne seraient pas les victimes expiatoire.
Ils ont fait comprendre que si jamais il
y avait la guerre, l'Arabie Saoudite
serait la première à trinquer.
Et les Émirats surtout
les Émirats surtout
Oui. D'accord. Je veux dire, ils ont
montré que si tu veux, ils avaient les
moyens de taper non pas sur les
États-Unis, mais de taper sur les alliés
proches. Ce qui évidemment ça a laissé
le Mohamed Ben Salman à pointe puisque
il pensait que Trump allait venir et
Trump qui avait fait monter la pression
he qui avait pas cessé de dire et cetera
l'Iran, l'Iran, rappelle-toi son
discours à l'ONU dans lequel il explique
que c'est l'Iran qui est responsable du
terrorisme du terrorisme qui est
responsable du 11 septembre quand il a
dénoncé l'accord sur le nucléaire dans
la déclaration lorsque Trump fait sa
déclaration disant qu'il sort de
l'accord sur nucléaire il rappelle le 11
septembre en disant que ce sont les
Iraniens à ma connaissance les pilotes
de l'air, c'était plutôt des Saoudiens
que des 15/ 19 saoudiens.
Mais si tu veux, ça te montre encore une
fois sur cette idée sur les États-Unis,
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a une école
doctrinale américaine qui est les
néoconservateurs qui sont capables de
penser que de on peut redessiner la
carte du monde avec du conflit, avec de
l'action armée. Et maintenant, ils sont
doublés ou ils sont soutenus par des
néo-évangéliques qui eux ont une lection
totalement théologique de la planète. Et
par exemple, faut te donner un exemple,
quand George Bush décide l'invasion de
l'Irak, tu as euh des prédicateurs
américains qui disent "Saddam Hussein,
c'est le nouveau Nabucodonosaure. C'est
donc lui, il va falloir il faut le tuer
parce que ça va libérer les Juifs,
permettre de créer le grand Israël et le
grand Israël est la condition pour que
revienne le Messie." Et alors le
évidemment pour les néovangéliques, le
Messie va venir donc tous les juifs
seront convertis. Alors comme tu
d'accord comme tu sais les juifs aussi
attendent le Messie mais c'est pas le
même. Et alors un jour il y a une
discussion entre Netaniaou et des néo
évangéliques. Et Netaniaou sait combien
il a besoin de ses néovangéliques. Il a
clut la discussion en disant écoutez le
jour où le Messie arrive, on lui posera
une seule question. Est-ce que c'est la
première fois ou est-ce que c'est la
deuxième fois que tu viens ?
Euh petite question sur le Liban et la
la gilégionisation
du Liban. Et euh
le
donc euh le gilionisation, c'est que
non ça enfin bien sûr, on peut toujours
dire que c'est une contestation sociale,
mais ce qui est très intéressant dans ce
qui se passe au Liban aujourd'hui.
Vous connaissez le Liban ?
Oui, j'en j'en rentre là, j'ai été je
suis rentré samedi soir de de Beou donc
j'ai j'ai su Non, pas du tout.
Euh mais ce qui est très intéressant,
c'est
le cabaret,
c'est que le
Michelades magnifique.
Non, je suis pas allé au cabaret. J'ai
plutôt regardé ce qui se passait et puis
aller discuter avec les les Libanais.
Mais ce qui est vraiment impressionnant
et intéressant dans ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui au Liban, c'est que vous
avez pour la première fois, c'est un
mouvement qui touche toutes les
communautés et toutes les régions du
Liban,
surtout tous les partis politiques sont
contestés
sur un seul mot d'ordre, on est libanais
et on veut la citoyenneté libanaise. Il
y a plus d'état. cet état é complètement
failli a démontrer son incapacité à
gérer le le le pays. Il y a pas
d'électricité, il y a pas d'eau, il y a
des ordures, les routes sont dans un
état catastrophique. On est libanais et
toute cette classe politique doit
dégager. Et ça c'est la fin d'un cycle
pour moi qui est la fin du cycle issu de
la guerre civile puisque'à la fin de la
guerre civile on a mis tous les chefs de
guerre autour de la table avec en les
rendant présentables pour qu'il se
partage le système et sans qu'il ait du
tout en plus de travail de
réconciliation et de d'apuré si je puis
dire le drame de cette guerre. Et
aujourd'hui, la jeune génération qui n'a
pas connu tout ça dit "Maintenant, on en
a marre, on est libanais, on veut un
état et on veut euh une citoyenneté
libanaise. On veut pouvoir se marier en
dehors de notre communauté et il y en a
marre.
Mais et d'autant plus la purité pour
les libanés vont un chip pour se marier.
Ben parce que aujourd'hui, ils sont
obligés de se marier dans leur
communauté alors que la constitution ne
l'impose pas. Et ce qui est absolument
extraordinaire, c'est que alors que la
Constitution permet un mariage civil, il
n'ent pas appliqué que les libanais sont
obligés de partir à Chypre lorsqu'ils ne
veulent pas d'un mariage religieux, donc
dans sa propre communauté. Et ce qui est
très intéressant aujourd'hui, c'est que
pour la première fois, il y a vraiment
des contestations aussi bien de tir à
Tripoli, à Nabatillé partout et à et à
Beou bien évidemment et que tous les
Libanais se retrouvent sur un mot
d'ordre. On est citoyen, on veut être
citoyen d'un pays et non plus appartenir
à telle communauté et dépendre de mon
Zim, donc mon chef qui va m'accorder la
protection. Pourquoi les Libanais
jusque-là on ont on ont été dans ce
système ? C'est que la seule personne
qui pouvait leur donner les moyens de de
pouvoir payer des frais de de santé ou
de pouvoir euh avoir accès à une école
parce que toutes les écoles sont
privées, c'était le Zim, donc le chef de
la communauté qui redistribue la man au
sien pour avoir sa clientèle qui vient
des marchés publics.
Absolument. Et donc aujourd'hui, il y a
ce rejet total de tout ce système
politique communautaire confessionnel
dans l'espoir de pouvoir mettre en
place, de créer un véritable état digne
de ce nom qui donnerait des des la
protection à tous les citoyens et de
plus être dépendant de ce Zari avec
toute la le côté pervers que ça
implique. Le système communautaire pour
moi ne peut conduire qu'à un système de
corruption et de prédation auquel nous
assistons au Liban tel qu'il fonctionne
parce que il s'agit de faire un
équilibre en permanence entre tous les
chefs communautaires et donc cet
équilibre qui est recherché ne peut
conduire qu'à ce système de corruption
puisqu'il faut se partager le gâteau et
à part égal pour qu'il n'y ait aucune
que que tout le monde se sente reconnu à
la à sa juste valeur par rapport aux
autres. Donc ce système tel qu'il a été
mis qui est le résultat de la guerre
civile et les fameux accords de TAF de
89 qui ont déterminé selon lequel le
président de la République est un
maronite, le président du parlement est
un chéit, le le premier ministre est
sunnite. C'est un système qui a démontré
les ruges, ils font quoi déjà ? Ils font
rien les Russes.
Non, mais ils sont au gouvernement parce
que Walid Jumlat a deux ministres qui
sont même au-delà de la représentativité
du pourcentage de la population de russe
au sein du système politique. Et donc ce
qui est formidable, je crois dans ce
mouvement, c'est que pour la première
fois, les Libanais disent maintenant on
veut essayer de construire un état, de
plus être dépendant de l'extérieur
puisque chaque communauté était
dépendante aussi de l'extérieur des
financements qui venaient de
l'extérieur. La communauté sunnite était
soutenue par l'Arabie Saoudite, le
Hzbola, soutenu par l'Iran, la
communauté nationale dont la France qui
venait régulièrement mettre de l'argent.
Et là, tout ça, ils disent on nen veut
plus maintenant, il faut qu'on qu'on
sorte de ce système qui nous a conduit à
la faillite. Faillite. Pas d'eau, pas
d'électricité. Pierre,
bah si tu veux, moi ce qui me frappe,
c'est que tous les systèmes
communautaristes, qui soient
démocratiques ou qui soient dans des
systèmes genre bout de ficelle comme les
États-Unis, comme le Liban ou même comme
l'Inde sont tous en crise. C'est-à-dire
que ça doit être une leçon pour la
France. Je prends un exemple qui est
très intéressant qui est celui de
l'Inde. En 47, il y a deux tendances
dans le nationalisme indien. Tu as
Gandhi et Nerou qui disent l'Inde est un
pays communautariste, ils appellent ça
secularism. C'est-à-dire en fait chaque
communauté aura le droit de se gérer
elle-même et donc faut que tous les
Indiens puissent vivre là. Et puis tu as
une autre tendance qui va
progressivement prendre le pouvoir, qui
va se concrétiser par l'arrivée au
pouvoir de Maudit qui dit non les qui
est hindou qu'est-ce que c'est que
l'industan qu'est-ce que c'est que le il
appelle ça l'indouva c'estàd qu'est-ce
que c'est que l'identité indienne c'est
les hindou les sik et les jaines donc
les musulmans dehors. Il va il va pas
l'emporter dans le parti du Congress
mais c'est un de ses disciples qui
assassine Gandhi. Bon donc Nerou qui
continue dit "D'accord, on installe le
système communautariste." Au fur et à
mesure, ce système communautariste a
pris du plan dans l'aile parce que tu as
eu progressivement une, comment dire une
expression hindou disant "Mais attendez,
pourquoi les musulmans ils auraient
droit à quatre femmes et nous pas ?
Pourquoi ils auraient droit un mois pour
aller faire le pèlerinage alors que nous
pour aller à Bénarè, il nous faut 12h et
cetera et cetera." Varanis
Varan assis, cher ami. Et donc, tu te
retrouves avec progressivement
l'expression de cette d'insistance sur
ces différences qui font que le système
communautariste a été attaqué par sa
caractéristique et qui fait que
aujourd'hui Budi, il dit "Bon ben c'est
fini, on supprime le statut particulier
du Cachmir, on supprime par exemple truc
extraordinaire, il y a en Inde un truc
qui s'appelle la guerre de la vache." La
guerre de la vache c'est puisque la
vache est sacrée, il y a pas de raison
que d'autres communautés puissent faire
du trafic de vache
emblème un emblème nationaliste. Et donc
tu tu non seulement les bouchés sont
musulmans, mais ils sont souvent des
intouchables. C'est-à-dire que tu as eu
des expéditions punitives sur des
bouchers musulmans qui ont été lychés
parce que les mecs disent "Non, c'est un
animal sacré, il faut interdire le
commerce de la vache." L'un était l'un
des plus gros exportateurs de vache.
Plus extraordinaire, le lof d jihad. Le
lof djihad, c'est prodigieux. Donc là
aussi, c'est c'est les nationalistes
adou. Ils disent "Les musulmans sont
certains jeunes musulmans sont mandatés
pour séduire des jeunes hindou femmes
pour qu'ensuite après le mariage elles
se convertissent. Et donc ils ont voté
une loi permettant aux parents de
demander l'annulation du mariage.
C'est c'est fort. Ça veut dire que quand
je dis que les systèmes communautariste
partout sont en difficulté, c'est pas
seulement qu'en Angleterre et en
Belgique, ils sont aussi en dans les la
plus grande démocratie du monde qui est
l'Inde. Et donc à force de ne pas
traiter cette question là, de pas
considérer que le citoyen est un citoyen
et pas un individu de telle catégorie,
tu te retrouves avec des situations
violentes. Et la minorité musulmane en
Inde, c'est quand même 190 millions de
personnes. Donc c'est une petite grosse
minorité, tu vois. Agnès, on va revenir
un peu sur le Liban. Quand
un libanais très célèbre avait été
relativement kidnappé par un saoudien
très célèbre,
il a eu peur de terminer au coupe coupe
?
Ah, il aurait pu. Pourquoi pas ?
Qui était ce libanais très célèbre ? Et
qui était ce saoudien très célèbre ? En
fait, le premier ministre libanais Hafi
qui Saad Khdon qui est le fils de de son
père et donc premier ministre est
convoqué par les Saoudiens. Ce que ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que le premier
le premier ministre libanais a trois
passeports.
Un passeport libanais, ce qui est assez
normal, un passeport saoudien et un
passeport français. Donc dépendant des
subventions saoudiennes, quand l'Arabie
Saoudite lui demande de venir, le
convoque, il prend le premier avion et
il part en Arabie Saoudite puisqu'il est
quand même sujet euh saoudien.
Donc il arrive en Arabie Saoudite et là
le le le prince héritier lui dit "Ça va
pas du tout, tu es quand même beaucoup
trop gentil avec le Hizbollah." Le
Hizbollah étant le parti chez Tibanais
qui dépend de l'Iran. Et au moment où
l'Arabie Saoudite est en guerre contre
l'Iran, en guerre pas physique hein,
mais en tous les cas veut régler son
compte à à l'Iran. Donc du coup MBS
convoque Hair pour lui dire "Bon
maintenant, il faudrait quand même que
tu changes un peu les choses. Il est pas
possible que tu sois à ce point. Il faut
que tu fasses en sorte de de de que le
Hizbollah n'ait plus aucun pouvoir. Sauf
que Harry, il a beau être premier
ministre, il peut de toute façon rien
faire et que c'est un homme politique
qui est particulièrement faible. Euh Sad
Hi, il a absolument pas l'ura de son
père et en plus étant en grande
difficulté économique en Arabie Saoudite
parce que son père a fait fortune en
Arabie Saoudite dans le BTP, il a été
obligé de licencier tout le monde.
D'ailleurs, il y a encore beaucoup de
ces employés qui n'ont toujours pas été
payés, ce qui est quand même un gros
problème.
Et donc comme il a aussi un passeport
français comme je disais au départ quand
on s'est aperçu que que Sad était retenu
en Arabie Saoudite
la France
du coup et en plus à l'époque Macron est
en visite en dans les Émirats arabes
unis ce qui est quand même pas très
loin. Donc du coup, Macron est allé voir
Mohamen Zayed qui est le prince héritier
des Émirats arabes uniques qui est les
grands camarades de MBS, le prince
héritier saoudien pour dire bon faut
faire quelque chose, on peut pas quand
même accepter cette situation. Et donc
MBZ a arrangé une une rencontre entre
Macron et MBS qui a fait un saut en
avion en Arabie Saoudite et ce qui a
permis à Sad Heri de sortir, de venir en
France et de rentrer au Liban dans ces
conditions. Bon, tout ça démontre quand
même la faiblesse, c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire, du premier ministre
libanais, du fait que d'avoir plusieurs
passeports comme ça, ça peut un moment
ou un autre poser des problèmes
et
à la France
et que MBS là encore, c'est à mon avis
complè on n pas eu le temps d'en parler
mais c'est vrai que la politique
régionale de de l'Arabie Saoudite
aujourd'hui est quand même une
catastrophe absolue puisqu'on voit bien
que MBS est dans s'est planté si vous me
passez expression sur tous les dossiers
de politique régionale que ce soit avec
avec le Liban et le cet épisode quand
même n'a pas démontré un coup de génie
diplomatique de la part du prince
héritier. L'affaire à chaud, on en a
parlé, l'affaire du Yémen qui est quand
même une catastrophe et
et et le la crise au sein des pays du
Golf puisque comme vous le savez, vous
vous souvenez peut-être, l'Arabie
Saoudite mais surtout les Émirats arabes
unis ont mis au banc des pays du golfe
le Qatar. Et donc la seule instance
régionale qui existait et qui
fonctionnait assez bien qui s'appelle le
conseil de coopération du golf qui
réunit l'Arabie Saoudite, le Qatar, les
Émirats Bah Kuwait et le Sultan Adoman
qui est la seule instance régionale qui
fonctionnait assez bien aujourd'hui a
volé en éclat puisque l'Arabie Saoudite
et les Émirats ont mis le Qatar
complètement au banc en fermant
complètement les frontières, en fermant
l'espace aérien et vous avez du coup
aujourd'hui un conseil de coopération du
golf qui ne fonctionne plus puisque
parce que le Qatar est mis de côté, que
le Kit n'a de cesse que d'essayer de
faire une médiation pour rabibaucher la
situation. et le Sultan Adoman qui est
aussi dans une position assez autonome
par rapport à l'Arabie Saoudite. Donc
vous avez un clan Emirat Arabie Bahrain
parce que le Bahlin est un satellite de
l'Arabie Saoudite, le Qatar qui est mise
au banc et le cohité oman qui essaie de
faire en sorte que le le ce conseil de
coopération du golfe puisse revivre
puisque ce conseil avait été créé en
1981 pour faire face à la révolution
islamique en Iran puisque lorsque les
les les MOL ont pris le pouvoir en Iran
en 79, ça a été une grande panique dans
les pays du golf qui se sont dit que
l'Iran allait vouloir, puisque c'était
un des objectifs de de l'Iran, exporter
sa révolution islamique dans les pays de
la région. Et donc les pays du golf
paniqués à l'idée de cette expansion, de
cette exportation de la révolution
islamique ont créé ce conseil de
coopération du golf pour se protéger et
du coup le seul terrain finalement de
réussite de l'exportation de la
révolution islamique ça a été au Liban
avec la création de Hzbolah et donc le
seul exemple véritablement qui a pu à
peu près fonctionner. Donc MBS, si on
reprend tous les les les sujets de
politique régional, s'est planté sur
absolument tous les sujets. Et le plus
dramatique étant la guerre au Yémen
puisque depuis 2015, il y a une
coalition occidentale, enfin coalition
menée par l'Arabie Saoudite pour et qui
bombarde
très très régulièrement avec beaucoup de
morts civiles puisque la l'armée
saoudienne voilà n'est pas encore très
très efficace et le l'Iran, l'Arabie a
beau avoir un matériel extrêmement
perfectionné n'arrive pas du tout à se
sortir de cette guerre puisqu'il y aura
pas de solution militaire à la guerre au
Yémen. Il peut y avoir qu'une solution
politique et donc le fait de bombarder
ne permet pas de régler la situation.
Voilà.
Ah, j'aime bien une solution politique.
Oui, je sais que vous êtes attendu. On
va on va on va pas trop tarder.
Une remarque juste une remarque à propos
du Yémen.
Dans le système de lobby saoudien, si tu
veux, le Yémen à Paris, évidemment le le
Yémen est une question grave puisque
quand même tout le monde sait ce qui s'y
passe.
Attends, il s'est passe quoi ? Non non,
c'est le bombardement si tu veux, le
fait que la famille est installée
installée, que il y a une crise du cholé
française
entre
en partie,
on sera on sera poursuivi pour crime
contre l'humanité par Non
non, on sera pas poursuivi pour crime
contre l'humanitaire
parce qu'on a on parce qu'on juge c'est
ça tout est dans la nuance. Par exemple,
les canons César sont du côté de la
frontière saoudienne et ils tirent sur
le Yémen mais ils disent c'est pour
empêcher les infiltrations. Donc on a
calculé, il y a à peu près 500000
personnes qui sont exposées au tir du
Canon César. Mais ils sont du côté
saoudien.
Donc côté
donc c'est du système défensif.
Non, les canons sont d'accord.
Les canons sont saoudiens mais ils sont
côté saoudien. Ils bombardent les
reviens une minute sur le Yémen. Pardon
?
40 km de portée.
Oui, c'est ça. Donc alors je reviens une
minute sur le Yémen parce que dans le
système de l'oby si tu veux évidemment
le Yémen, c'est le dossier sensible.
C'est-à-dire que c'est un peu comme
Cachoi, c'est le vraiment le système
dans lequel le l'Arabie Saoudite se
trouve en position d'accuser. Donc il y
a eu des voyages organisés justement par
ce système que je vous ai décrit
rapidement pour aller au Yémen en
arrivant par les Émirats arabunistes,
qui est quand même effectivement assez
original. Et sur le tout pour essayer de
constater combien l'aide humanitaire
distribuée par les Émirats Arabes Unis
et l'Arabie Saoudite finalement aider
les populations. Donc ce sont des
sénateurs qui sont allés là-bas. Et
effectivement, tu pourras trouver sur
France 24 une interview d'une sénatrice
qui après avoir fait cette mission
humanitaire a visité les centres de
déradicalisation saoudien et elle
explique combien la France devrait s'en
as inspirer. Tu trouves ça sur France 24
? Effectivement, c'est vrai que le
système de déradicalisation saoudien est
formidable puisque tu transformes un
salafiste en whabit, ce qui est quand
même moins compliqué que d'en faire un
démocrate. Donc tu te retrouves dans
avec des gens qui sont capables de tenir
devant des caméras ce genre de discours.
P
ah je sais pas moi je moi mal je sais
pas. Tu comprends ce que je veux dire ?
C'est que c'est comment tu joues sur une
opinion ou comment ensuite ton
commanditaire va aller se servir de ton
truc pour le mettre sur les réseaux
arabe pour dire regardez effectivement
il y a des sénateurs français qui
Donc un dernier mot puis on va vous
demander trois bouquins et un conseil
pour les jeunes générations. Alors une
question pour Agnè est-ce que le Maghreb
est toujours perçu par les Saoudiens
comme les Roumains de seconde zone
européen ? Est-ce que le Maghreb est
perçu par le le le Moyen-Orient comme
des des Arabes de seconde zone ?
En fait, le Maghreb est considéré par
exemple les Saoudiens ont des palais au
Maroc, vont passer leurs vacances,
ils ont des [__] au Liban,
ils ont mais aussi au Maroc euh
sont considérés comme des endroits pour
certains droit qu'on peut acheter. C'est
le cas de du Maroc et de la Tunisie.
L'Algérie c'est plus compliqué parce que
les Algériens c'est un vrai pays, ils
ont un vrai caractère. pas il se laisse
pas ils se laissent pas acheter les voit
pas au Ymen parce que les 10 ans de
guerre civile qu'on a eu c'est la faute
des Saoudiens.
Absolument.
Donc c'était
donc c'est vrai
j'attendais je voulais vous emmener vers
ça.
Donc c'est vrai qu'il faut vraiment
distinguer dans pour l'Arabie Saoudite
et les pays du golf. Le Maghreb il faut
vraiment distinguer les pays.
C'est-à-dire que le Maroc c'est un
endroit c'est une monarchie. le Maroc
comme les pays du golf. Souvenez-vous au
moment des des révolutions arabes, la
l'Arabie Saoudite a proposé au Maroc et
à la Jordanie de rejoindre le Conseil de
coopération du golf au nom de ces
monarchies qui ont le même mode de
fonctionnement et qui peuvent
s'entendre. le Maroc et la Jordanie ont
quand même préféré euh euh ces gens-là
et et éviter de se laisser embarquer
dans cette proposition de l'Arabie
Saoudite. Mais c'est donc pour dire
simplement que pour les pays du golf, le
Maroc c'est chez eux, ils font à peu
près ce qu'ils veulent et euh il y a des
des intérêts bien entendu partagés des
de côtés. La Tunisie est un pays petit
pays qui a qui a besoin de ressources et
donc a besoin des capitaux des des pays
du golf. Et donc il y a il y a une un
sentiment de la part de ces pays du golf
qui peuvent acheter à peu près ce qu'ils
veulent et l'Algérie donc on met à part
parce que l'Algérie n'est pas un pays
d'abord un pays qui a de l'argent et qui
a des ressources et qui n'est pas
dépendant des pays du golfe comme
peuvent l'être le Maroc et la Tunisie.
Mohamed 6 c'est un roi.
C'est un roi. Alors je vais faire une
réponse de diplom de diplomate.
C'està-dire
non mais le le Mohamed 6 a beaucoup
développé le Maroc d'un point de vue
interne c'est les Marocains
reconnaissent qu'il y a eu un certain
nombre d'investissements qui ont été
faits pour développer le Maroc. ce que
n'avait pas fait Hassan 2, son père qui
était beaucoup plus intéressé par la
diplomatie et par ses relations
internationales où il passait beaucoup
plus de temps. Maintenant, il y a un
certain nombre de questions sur les
choix qui ont été faits sur les choix
qui ont été faits. Par exemple, le TGV,
est-ce que c'était le meilleur
investissement à faire quand on connaît
le niveau de vie des des Marocains et
qu'il y avait peut-être d'autres
infrastructures à mettre en place que
celle-ci ? Et beaucoup de Marocains
reconnaissent que ce qu'il a réussi,
c'est toute la création de hub
industriel que ce soit à Casablanca pour
tout ce qui sont les métiers de
l'aéronautique que ce soit à Tanger avec
Med Tanger Med et avec le Renault toutes
les usines automobiles et maintenant le
fait que le Maroc est un hub
d'exportation vers l'Afrique
sub-saharienne. Donc il y a il y a eu
des choses qui ont été faites mais une
gestion en tous les cas de la du social
qui est quand même très très
problématique et avec une et on l'a bien
vu dans la gestion des manifestations
que ce soit dans le rif ou autre là qui
est quand même catastrophique. Et donc
on voit bien que le Maroc est incapable
de gérer ce genre de situation. Et le
dernier exemple qui est cette jeune
journaliste qui a été emprisonnée et qui
a été finalement gracié par le roi très
peu de temps auparavant qui démontre à
mon avis l'incapacité
de du Maroc à pouvoir gérer ce genre
d'histoire qui est pas qui est une
histoire incroyable enfin quand on
reprend le le dérouler qui n'a aucun
sens et qui
monte une absence totale de gestion. Ce
qui est beaucoup reproché au roi, c'est
quand même de n jamais en fait de nêre
d'être très peu présent au Maroc.
Pierre, un mot sur l'Algérie. On on voit
beaucoup nous, on a une communauté en
Algérie qui nous envoie beaucoup de
photos de manifestations
avec beaucoup de personnes dans les rues
et je trouve que on on entend pas
beaucoup parler dans les médias
français.
Bon, moi j'ai peu suivi l'Algérie, hein,
mais c'est vrai que l'Algérie est un
pays dont l'identité, si tu veux, est
une identité problématique parce que
elle est à la fois arabophone et
francophone. Donc, tu as toujours une
partie de la communauté qui reproche à
l'autre
et Kabile ?
Oui. Alors, en plus, alors non, mais
attends, attends parce que tu as
francophone, arabophone, ensuite tu as
arabe, kabile
et ensuite tu as tiriste et puis
nécessité d'être rattaché à l'endroit où
est l'argent, c'estàd les pays
occidentaux. C'est-à-dire, c'est un pays
dont l'identité est déchirée entre
plusieurs composantes. Et c'est vrai que
tu as tu as encore de temps en temps des
hommes politiques français qui vont
parler du parti de la France. Quand ils
veulent discréditer un de leurs
opposants, ils vont dire que c'est un
type qui est mandaté par la France. Donc
d'ici qu'ils utilisent ça pour expliquer
que les manifestants sont payés par la
France. Si la France avait tant
d'argent, ce serait formidable. Et donc
cette vie politique algérienne a été
tellement pervertie par 25 ans de
pouvoir du FLN puis ensuite par le
pouvoir des militaires qu'effectivement
quand tu as une expression spontanée
comme celle-là, tu as une classe
politique qui est incapable d'y apporter
une réponse. Soit les militaires se
direent "On va perdre le pouvoir et donc
il faut qu'on trouve une média un moyen
de garder le pouvoir." Et puis la classe
politique, rappelle-toi cette omominie
de représenter Boutfica encore une fois
pour un 4e mandat alors qu'il était à
peine capable de trouver l'ure. il
fallait l'amener jusqu'au pied de l'urne
et lui tenir la main. Donc je veux dire
cette classe politique est capable de
traiter cette population de cette
manière là. Tu imagines ce degré de
honte, ce degré de de mépris que ça peut
représenter pour la classe politique ?
important c'était gardons le pouvoir.
Bon donc est-ce que cette classe
politique elle va être effectivement
disparaître avec le avec j'espère avec
la crise mais il y a pas de solution
alternative il y a pas de de
personnalité politique. J'aime pas enfin
j'ai beaucoup de mal avec cette façon
qu'on a toujours de dire qu'il y a pas
de solution alternative. Il y en a marre
de ça. Je pense que c'est c'est c'est
quelque chose enfin qu'on a vu dans tous
les mouvements de contestation. à chaque
fois on dit il y a pas d'alternative
donc finalement ben on va faire avec et
puis ça ça va continuer. Non ce qui est
clair aujourd'hui c'est que les jeunes
générations disent on nen peut plus et
je trouve qu'il y a des similitudes
entre l'Algérie et le Liban même si ça
n'a rien à voir dans dans l'histoire.
Paris aussi hein. Paris aussi.
Oui mais et moi je suis frappé
aujourd'hui quand je vois ce qui se
passe au Liban. C'est le même ralbol de
cette classe politique qui a été
incapable de gérer le pays qui s'en est
mis plein les poches qui a qui a
accumulé des richesses Paris là. Non
non non parle du Liban. Je parle du
Liban et l'Algérie et avec des élites
politiques qui sont plus des élites qui
sont rien et qui à part qui qui essayent
simplement de survivre enfin de de
maintenir leur survie, ils en ont rien à
faire du pays et il y a simplement
aujourd'hui ces élites qui simplement
ont peur de la rue. Ce qui est frappant
aujourd'hui, c'est que jusque là,
c'était des des populations qui étaient
tétanisées par ces régimes des régime
alors pas dans le cas du Liban, mais en
Algérie un régime autoritaire avec des
services
qui qui qui fonctionnait. Euh
aujourd'hui dans le cas du Liban, c'est
clair, la classe politique est tétanisée
par le par la rue. Il un homme politique
le ministre le ministre, je crois que
c'est le ministre des finances qui est
sorti avec son garde du corps.
Non, c'est le l'ancien alors à Tripoli
quand j'étais vendredi dernier, il y a
eu l'ancien député de Tripoli qui était
pas le pire en plus hein. Miss Bar qui
est qui est sorti dans la rue avec ses
gardes du corps. Ses gardes du corps. Il
y a une telle mobilisation de toutes les
manifestations lui ont dit de dégager.
Du coup, ils ont tiré, il y a eu un mort
et cette blessée. Et la veille jeudi
soir à Beyro, pareil, il y avait le
ministre là de c'est les
télécoméducation, je sais plus lequel
des deux qui a voulu qui est passé là
juste après l'annonce de la taxe sur le
WhatsApp et là pareil les gardes du
corps ont commencé à tirer là il y a pas
de mort et ils sont vite partis. Donc il
y a pas un homme politique aujourd'hui
au Liban qui peut descendre dans les
manifestations. Le moindre député ou
ministre se fait complètement lych par
la population.
France on on n'est pas loin. Non
je travaille pas sur la France. Moi je
tra le monde arabe.
C'est comme le mec de la DGSU qui dit
qu'il travaille pas sur la France.
C'està-dire que cette classe politique a
tellement monopolisé toutes les
structures de pouvoir que il y a aucune
expression dissidente qui a une
légitimité aux yeux de la rue. Alour
peut-être peut-être mais en Algérie si
tu veux, il faut quand même se souvenir
que quand il y a eu un gouvernement qui
a essayé de gérer les émotes de 88 800
morts dans les rues he c'està-dire
autant que dans la deuxème intifada et
donc tu te retrouvais avec un
gouvernement amourouche avec un boudf
qui est assassiné par les militaires.
C'est-à-dire que les hommes politiques
savent aussi qu'il y a des choses qui ne
peuvent pas se faire. Et donc tu tu es
quand même dans une situation politique
bloquée. Donc quand il va y avoir un
minimum de bordel, on va dire non mais
c'est pas possible et cetera, tu risques
d'avoir le retour des militaires en
disant nous on va privilégier l'ordre.
Voilà. Donc est-ce que la France a les
moyens est-ce que la France a les moyens
de peser là-dessus ? Non. La France n'a
aucun moyen de peser là-dessus.
Agè sur les alternatives et les choses
comme ça ?
Non. Ce que je crois c'est alors le cas
du du Livan est différent de ce point de
vue là de l'Algérie, même si en Algérie
il y a des partis politiques et il y a
une expression quand même hein. Donc je
c'est aussi là qu'il y a sûrement un
travail à faire de la part de nos
diplomatie de façon générale pour
comprendre voir quels sont ces
mouvements qui existent et pour
éventuellement le alors faut pas trop
les aider parce que si on les aide de
toute façon c'est Haran et c'est pire
que tout. Donc de toute façon, je pense
qu'on a vraiment intérêt à se tenir un
peu à distance. Mais au Liban, on l'a
bien vu dans les élections l'année
dernière, les élections législatives en
mai 2018 où on a vu des mouvements alors
ce qu'on appelle les mouvements de la
société civile. Alors, j'ai toujours un
peu de mal avec cette expression parce
qu'on sait pas très bien ce que ça veut
dire mais on a vu quand même des
expressions des mouvements qui aspirent
à autre chose et il y a eu quelques
mouvements comme Irada Kuluna, il y a eu
fidou citoyen citoyenne dans un état.
La simple expression de ce mouvement
citoyen, citoyenne dans un état, il y a
aucune référence à aucune communauté, à
aucun communautarisme ou autre qui est
simplement la volonté justement de
l'émergence d'une citoyenneté. Il y a
des mouvements comme ça qui existent qui
alors ils ont pas pu l'année dernière
avoir beaucoup de représentants aux
élections, ils ont eu un député parce
que la machine de guerre des partis
politiques est tellement forte que il
faut avoir des moyens pour résister en
face de ces partis politiques. Puisque
quand au Liban pour la campagne
électorale, pour que votre spot
publicitaire passe dans les télés, il
faut payer parce que toutes les chaînes
sont privées. Donc ils ont pas eu de
revendivité mais que le mouvement se
déclenche un an, un peu plus d'un an
après ces élections qui ont quand même
vu à ce moment-là l'émergence de ces
mouvements de la société, tant pis si on
appelle société civile et on sait pas
très bien ce que ça veut dire mais de
ces mouvements qui ont émergé, ça veut
dire qu'il y a quand même quelque chose
et qu'il y a pas un néant absolu et que
c'est pas eux ou le chaos, il y a autre
chose. Il y a des forces qui existent.
Bon, comment elles vont pouvoir
s'organiser ? Est-ce que les le pouvoir
est-ce que les partis les vieux partis
vont les laisser faire ? C'est pas sûr.
On a déjà vu la milice de Nabiberry
essayer de de d'intervenir dans les
manifestations et l'armée les a les a
arrêté pour éviter justement qu'il y ait
des dérapages sanglants. Donc on n'est
évidemment pas à l'abri de dérapage. On
n'est évidemment pas à l'abri
d'utilisation par le régime de la force
pour essayer de d'arrêter ce mouvement
parce que fait significatif au Liban,
les banques sont fermées depuis vendredi
dernier. Ça n'était jamais arrivé dans
ce pays où l'économie est roie, où la
banque centrale est reine, où le dollar
est roi. Que les banque soit fermé aussi
longtemps, même en 2006 de lorsqu'il y a
eu la guerre avec Israël, les banques
n'ont pas été fermées 7 jours d'affilé.
Et là, on est vendredi demain, elles
rouvriront peut-être lundi et c'est pas
sûr, ça fera 10 jours. Ce qui veut donc
dire que là, la situation devient
vraiment très grave et que le pouvoir
est incapable de réagir, est incapable
de proposer quoi que ce soit. qui soit
acceptable par la par la par la la les
manifestants qui sont qui sont dans la
rue.
Le cas du Liban comme le cas de
l'Algérie, comme le cas de la Syrie, de
l'Irak, enfin un certain nombre de pays
montre que la corruption n'est pas qu'un
phénomène économique, c'est un phénomène
stratégique. C'est-à-dire qu'au bout
d'un certain temps, depuis tréfaction de
la classe politique qui s'est tellement
habitué à taper dans la caisse, émarger
sur les contrats et cetera, si tu veux,
l'État perd sa consistance et donc quand
tu as des manifestations, tu n'as plus
d'expression politique capable de
canaliser cette truc parce que tout le
monde pense que tous les hommes
politiques sont pourris. Et donc à
chaque fois on a traité la question en
disant "Oui mais par exemple, moi je me
souviens en Algérie
avec ce côté provoquant que j'aime bien,
je le avais dit aux Algériens mais vous
savez au moins par l'époque de la
colonisation la bourgeoisie elle
investissait sur place tandis que
maintenant la bourgeoisie qui tape dans
la caisse elle investit à Paris donc
c'est plus intéressant pour nous parce
que c'est la réalité c'est-à-dire que de
n'avoir jamais voulu lutter contre la
corruption internationale de n'avoir
jamais tenté de maîtriser nos
entreprises, on a des pays qui se sont
décomposés. C'est le cas en Afrique dans
beaucoup d'endroits. Et donc quand on a
fait la convention OCDE si tu veux en 97
pour lutter contre la corruption sur les
marchés internationaux, chacun des pays
a essayé de trouver comment éviter
d'appliquer la chose. L'initiative était
américaine puisque c'était partie
c'était partie de l'affaire des des
lukid en Italie. C'est-à-dire
qu'effectivement, ils avaient tellement
payé la classe politique italienne que
ça a fini par exploser. Donc les
industriels américains ont dit "Ben
attendez, si vous nous empêchez nous de
corrompre mais que vous laissez les
autres, il y a une distorsion de
concurrence.
On va choper tout. Donc du coup, ils ont
proposé cette conférence au CDE et
cetera. Et donc chacun des pays
développés a essayé, ça couvrait quand
même 90 % du commerce mondial hein,
chacun des pays a essayé de trouver le
faux fuyant. C'est-à-dire les anglais
ont dit mais nous nous avons une loi
contre la corruption qui d'ailleurs n'a
jamais donné lieu a à truc. C'est donc
il y a pas de corruption chez nous. Les
Américains, ils ont inventé le PL
bargaining. Le P bargaining, ça veut
dire qu'un entreprise qui est coincée
parce qu'elle a payé dans une un truc,
il peut plaider devant le juge et à ce
moment-là, il y a pas de procès. Donc on
ça ne porte pas atteinte à l'image de
l'entreprise mais il paye. Bon, c'est
une manière comme une autre de pas
rendre public si tu veux les distorsions
de la société américaine. En France, ça
a été encore d'autres trucs et cetera et
cetera. Donc on est, tu vois, on est
dans cette situation où la corruption
qu'on croyait est une espèce de
mécanisme économique à la limite de
régulation est un phénomène stratégique
qu'on a jamais voulu considérer comme
tel. Et on se retrouve dans des pays
comme l'Algérie ou comme le comme le
Liban dans un truc où tu ne peux pas
reconstituer une classe politique parce
que c'est l'ensemble de cette classe
politique qui a été considérée comme
corrompu.
Il se fait très tard. Euh donc je vais
vous je vais je vais vous je vais je
t'avais dit que tu allais pas voir le
temps passer le donc les deux dernières
question c'est pas une question c'est
trois bouquins
et laisser un conseil pour les jeunes
générations. Donc il faut nous proposer
trois bouquins. Un conseil pour les
jeunes générations et je vais en
rajouter un. Une laisser un conseil pour
le qu d'ors
ça c'est vraiment dernière question est
la plus compliquée.
Ah oui vraiment. On commence par
celle-là. Agnè, un conseil pour le qued
d'orsais,
bah de enfin pour continuer le bon
non, mais d'être à l'écoute de ce qui se
passe. C'està-dire et pour certains
d'entre eux, ils le font mais pour ceux
qui sont un peu trop dans les salons
d'aller beaucoup plus sur le terrain.
Voilà.
Trois livres.
Trois livres, je pense à l'athlète du
Moyen-Orient
que je trouve bien parce que ça permet
quand même de de chagnolo et blanc. Ah
ouais
et je trouve que c'est bien parce que
c'est clair et ça permet d'avoir des
idées très
après tout dépense des des sujets sur
lesquels on est intéressé quoi. C'est
ça.
Poésie
poésie. Alors moi j'adore les romans
parce que je trouve qu'il y a des romans
arabes formidables et le dernier bouquin
d'Ala sur l'Égypte est formidable et
j'ai couru vers le Nil et je trouve que
et il y a un bouquin alors j'ai plus le
titre en tête saoudien d'un d'un
romanciel sa et la ceinture qui est un
vieux livre enfin un roman de quelques
années et qui permet de comprendre la
société saoudienne qui est merveilleuse
donc s'appelle la ceinture
voilà c'est
un conseil pour les jeunes génération
ensuite à Pierre
on veut pas faire comme ça je réfléchis
pendant ce tempsl
OK Pierre alors un conseil pour le qui
est d'orsais Le conseil d'avorcé, c'est
les modif,
les modifications de structure dont je
te parlais tout à l'heure. C'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui dans un monde de la
mondialisation, il faut des spécialistes
de chacune des erreurs géographiques. Et
donc c'est pas uniquement une question
de pouvoir, c'est une question de
comment dire de de capacité
d'appréhension de la de réalité
complexe. Tu peux pas d'un seul coup
passer de l'Indonésie au Brésil. Tu peux
être aussi intelligent que tu veux. Tu
peux être aussi diplômé que tu veux. Il
y a quand même un arrière-fond d'une
connaissance du temps long qui s'est
brutalement révélé avec la disparition
de l'Estouest et qui fait que tu peux
pas dire la Syrie c'est Assad. La Syrie
c'est 1000 ans d'histoire ou 1500 ans
d'histoire. Tu peux pas dire à des
musulmans qui te parlent des croisades
que oui mais les croisades s'est passé
longtemps. C'est une identité qui a
marqué profondément une une culture.
Donc si tu veux si tu n'as pas cette
connaissance du temps long donc si tu
n'as pas étudié l'air géographique dans
laquelle tu es nommé tu ne peux pas la
reconstituer d'un coup. Bon, ça c'est le
premier truc. Donc il faut changer les
modes de de de recrutement
pour le Et encore une fois, les les gens
du kéor sont des gens intelligents. Mais
c'est la le système qui les rendeme
c'est le système. Donc euh deuxème chose
peut-être non un conseil pour la DRPP.
Bah la DRPP si tu veux c'est de
raisonner en se disant quel est le bon
spécialiste du pays dans lequel je veux
l'envoyer pas de se dire oui mais si je
l'envoie dans ce pays-là il va devenir
le le le type qui va plaider la cause du
pays dans lequel il est affecté à Paris
arrêton arrêton
direction du renseignement de la
préfecture de police. Ah, de la
préfecture de police. Ça c'est une autre
question si tu veux. Encore une fois,
c'est le débat aujourd'hui. Il y a une
impréation. Voilà, je vais un des
bouquins que je te conseille, c'est un
bouquin d'Alain Chouet qui s'appelle Au
cœur des services de renseignement. Et
je cite celui-là parce que c'est un type
qui a alerté pendant toute sa carrière
ou en tout cas depuis les années 2000 ou
même avant sur la montée de l'islamisme.
Or évidemment, il n'a pas été écouté.
Donc c'est pour ça que ce type mérite
qu'on lui rend hommage parce que il a
plaidé ce queon essaie de dire depuis le
début. On essaie de l'intérieur de faire
quelque chose. Le deuxième bouquin que
je le que je plaidrai dans une totale
immodestie, c'est de lire la fabrication
de l'ennemi qui est le bouquin que j'ai
Oui. J'ai écrit moi-même parce que c'est
20 ans d'expérience dans les affaires
stratégiques. Voilà.
Donc sur le sur le et puis Agnès a
raison parce que pour comprendre une
guerre civile, le meilleur moyen c'est
le roman. Parce que le roman, ça te met
au niveau des gens qui se retrouvent
tout à coup avec un voisin qui a été
leur voisin pendant des années qui tout
à coup devient l'ennemi. C'est le le
Serbe qui a qui habitait à côté du
Croate et qui tout à coup se retrouve
pris dans une guerre civile dont il
devient moi la première réaction que
j'avais eu quand je suis allé au Liban,
c'était la fin de la guerre civile, je
me disais je suis venu dans ce pays il y
a une dizaine d'années, je n'ai
strictement rien vu. Pourquoi je n'ai
rien vu ? Donc je vais dans une
librairie, je dis je voudrais savoir si
vous avez des romans écrits sur cette
période-là parce que je voulais
comprendre la mécanique intellectuelle,
c'est pas l'analyse froide. de l'homme
politique ou du chercheur, c'est la
sensibilité qui fait qu'un individu va
massacrer son voisin parce qu'il dit "Si
je le tue pas, c'est lui qui me tue." Tu
comprends ? Ça c'est la mécanique de la
guerre civile. Donc les romans, bon
Agnès a une plus grande culture que moi
sur les les romans qui touchent à ce à
cette région mais
l'état de barbarie de Michel Sora quand
même pour la région.
Ouais. Par exemple, si tu veux, il y a
un type moi que j'admire beaucoup
travailler sur le monde arabe, c'est
Nabil Mouline. Nabil Mouline, c'est le
seul qui a travaillé sur les clairs
saoudiens. Ça veut dire que tout ce
pilier essentiel de la société
saoudienne, pas Mohamed Ben Salman et
ses photos sur papier glacé, les mecs
qui sont derrière ceux qui t'expliquent
que Mickey Mouse est effectivement une
créature diabolique. Cela il y a que lui
qui a travaillé dessus. Donc ça, ce type
mérite d'être salué. Moi je le connais
pas donc je peux le dire tranquillement
mais tu vois c'est pour te dire que tu
as des pépites comme ça et ces pépites
sont des gens qui n'ont pas parfois
l'accès à une classe politique qui a
d'ailleurs aucune envie d'écouter pour
certains endroit. Donc un conseil pour
les jeunes générations et on finira pour
le conseil pour les jeunes générations
par Agès. Donc Pierre
conseil pour les jeunes générations. Ben
continue à travailler parce qu'il faut
payer nos retraites quoi.
d'être curieux et d'essayer quand il se
passe quelque chose de pas s'arrêter
juste à ce qui se passe mais d'essayer
de de regarder, d'avoir la curiosité de
comprendre et de pas se laisser en
embringuer par des soit des explications
rapides qu'on peut glaner n'importe où,
mais de faire vraiment attention et de
vraiment d'avoir cette curiosité d'aller
au-delà et de pas se laisser prendre par
des des trucs rapides
où on dit n'importe quoi et de prendre
le temps
voyager et voyager
comme chez nous.
Écoutez, ce fut fort agréable et très
intéressant. Donc on vous recevra encore
si vous le voulez bien tous les deux.
Euh c'était vraiment très sympa et Agnè
merci beaucoup.
[Musique]